Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Chaos Radio 268, wo wir heute über Attribution reden wollen. Wer war's gewesen? Und zwar beim Einbruch in digitale Systeme. Das wollen wir heute besprechen und dazu begrüße ich recht herzlich. Einerseits aus dem Clubumfeld könnte man sagen Vollkorn, auch einer der Sprecher vom Chaos Computer Club, arbeitet in der IT Security. Hallo und guten Abend. Wolpertwo, der in der sogenannten Incident Response arbeitet, auch das IT Security. Weitestens dann kann man vielleicht noch genauer erklären, was eine Incident Response ist. Hallo und guten Abend.
Hallo zusammen.
Und Hakan Tanriverdi, ein Journalist derzeit vor allem, und ich glaube ausschließlich beim Bayerischen Rundfunk, immer mit Themen zu tun haben, die auch in die Richtung Digitales zeigen. Hallo und guten Abend. Und gerade einen Podcast veröffentlicht haben, der sich genau mit dieser Frage beschäftigt, wenn auch in einem bisschen weiteren Kontext. Dazu sind wir heute tatsächlich sozusagen, das ist der Anlass, warum wir heute mal zusammengekommen sind, um über dieses Thema zu sprechen. Und wenn man in der Vergangenheit über dieses Thema gesprochen... Nee, stopp, halt. Liebe alle, mir ist bei der Vorbereitung eine Sache aufgefallen, und zwar, dass wenn erklärt wird, was Attribution ist, dann wird mittlerweile unironisch gesagt, es handelt sich dabei herauszufinden, wer Cyberangriffe verursacht hat oder Angriffe im Cyberraum passiert sind. Ab wann haben wir eigentlich aufgehört, Cyber als ironisches Tag zu benutzen, sondern als ernstzunehmendes Wort? Oder bin ich da in einer Fehlwahrnehmung aufgesessen?
Ja, das ist eine verdammt gute Frage. Ich glaube, langsam nutzen es so viele, dass auch all die Leute, die es ironisch immer benutzt haben, dazu übergegangen sind, zu sagen, ok, ok, dann wisst ihr zumindest, wovon ich rede. Also es ist ja der Standardbegriff, der in Regierungskreisen benutzt wird, der in jedem Gesetzesvorschlag heutzutage drin steckt, der in den Zeitungsartikeln drin steht. Also für mich persönlich zumindest ist es dann ein gewisses Zugeben, ok, jetzt hat sich der Begriff durchgesetzt und zumindest wissen die Leute dann, wovon wir reden.
Alles klar, genau, darum geht es heute, um Angriff auf den Cyberraum. Es gab einen ganz bestimmten, der der Anlass für den Podcast war, den Hakan zusammen mit Florian Flade gemacht hat, nämlich der Mann in Merkels Rechner, so heißt das Podcast auch. Da geht es um den Bundestagshack 2015. Also die eine Sache ist natürlich, wenn ihr das ganz genau wissen wollt, könnt ihr diesen Podcast hören, er hat fünf Teile. Und diese fünf Teile erzählen die ganze Geschichte, also inklusive auch so ein bisschen der politischen Verwicklung und dem, was hintendran noch passiert ist und was man so im Umfeld berichten kann. Die eigentliche Frage, nämlich die technische Frage, wie stelle ich denn eigentlich fest, wer in einem System drin war, nimmt einen Fünftel dieses Podcasts ein. Und quasi das wollen wir so ein bisschen genauer besprechen und dann noch ausweiten auf den Rest der Welt. Aber Hakan, kannst du für alle, die nur noch ganz dunkel so im Kopf haben, am Bundestagshack 2015, was war denn da noch mal los? Zusammenfassen, was da passiert ist, also was der Bundestagshack war.
Also es ist mittlerweile knapp sechs Jahre her und fast auf den Tag genau, weil am 30. April, nach allem, was man heute weiß, ist es Hackern gelungen, sich in dieses Netzwerk einzuhacken. Das lief damals über eine Spearfishing-E-Mail, da können wir auch noch gleich ein bisschen genauer drüber reden. Und das Spezielle an dem Fall waren, glaube ich, zwei Sachen. Das erste ist, das war das erste Mal tatsächlich, dass auf einem Parlament in dieser Art und Weise ein Hackerangriff stattgefunden hat. Es gab noch irgendwas vorher, 2009 drum, aber auf Regierungsebene, aber das war so 2015. Und das zweite ist, es wurde zeitgleich, fast zeitgleich öffentlich bekannt, als auch in den deutschen Behörden. Und das hat eine Situation ergeben, dass die Politik, die Abgeordneten, sehr verwirrt bis panisch waren. Es gibt Abgeordnete, die gesagt haben, bitte schreibt mir keine E-Mails, weil es kann auch sein, dass die Hacker, die mitlesen, und die wussten nicht genau, schalten wir jetzt das Parlament, ziehen wir den Stecker, geben wir eine verfühlte Sommerpause oder was machen wir eigentlich? Und das hat dann dazu geführt, dass über Monate hinweg tatsächlich bis in den Sommer hinein die Hacker drin waren. Die waren irgendwann nicht mehr aktiv, aber das war so dieses ganze Unsicherheitsgefühl, das vorherrschte. Zu einer Zeit, das vielleicht noch als letzten Satz, wo diese APT-Angriffe wirklich noch mal eine andere Medial zumindest, aber vielleicht auch in der Tragweite eine andere Qualität bekommen haben, das vielleicht für das Publikum von euch interessant ist. Im Monat vorher gab es einen Angriff auf TV St.Mont, wo dort der Fernsehsender gehackt wurde, zwar dieselbe Gruppe und so weiter und so fort.
Mir hat das neulich auf Twitter einer sozusagen so vorgehalten, ich wusste gar nicht, dass er schon so klar formuliert ist, aber es gibt im Chaosrad eine Regel. Wer einen Fremdbegriff einführt, muss ihn auch erklären. Was ist dein APT?
Das ist, wenn man Hackern unterstellt, dass sie sehr viel Zeit, sehr viele Fähigkeiten haben, um Ziele zu erreichen, die gefährlich sind für das Unternehmen, das gehackt wird. Industrie-Spionage, staatliche Spionage, solche Aspekte.
Und noch ganz kurz vielleicht in der Rückschau. Die Hacker waren im System. Bedeutet genau was, also weiß man, was die da gemacht haben?
Also so Standard vorgehen, wie es bei solchen Hackerangriffen passiert. Du kommst rein über eine Spearfishing-Mail, schaffst es dich dann auf relevante Systeme zu verbreiten. Dann bist du irgendwann Admin und hast das Active Directory übernommen und kannst dann eigentlich fast freischalten und walten, kannst auf Systeme zugreifen. Genau, und dann halt dort auf die Daten zugreifen und gucken, was für dich relevant ist, weitere Software nachladen, Backdoors installieren und so weiter.
Das heißt aber in dem Fall ging es vor allen Dingen darum, Daten rauszuziehen?
Das ist eine Hypothese. Genau 16 GB sind weggekommen nach allem, was man heute weiß. Es gibt unterschiedliche Zahlen, aber die, auf die man sich einigt, sind 16 GB. Aber das Problem ist, wenn du Daten ausleitest und es ist eine verschlüsselte Kommunikation, dann weißt du auch nicht, was sind das genau für Daten.
So, Spearfishing-Mail, das machen wir auch gleich. Ich würde jetzt gerne so aufziehen, wir reden jetzt über diesen Anlass, der für den Podcast gemacht hat, und dann weiten wir das immer so ein bisschen aus und fragen dann Vollkorn, Wolpertwo. Das haben wir also gehört, Hacker sind im System. Wir nennen das mittlerweile Cyberangriff. Könnt ihr das noch mal ein bisschen genauer eingrenzen? Also was fällt darunter und was fällt vielleicht auch nicht mehr darunter, wenn ein Cybersystem angegriffen wird?
Ja, ich glaube also der deutsche Fachbegriff wäre digitalisierte Fernspionage, wenn eben Spionage eben hauptsächlich mit Computern und über das Internet stattfindet und dann natürlich halt in irgendeiner Form eine Spionage Zielsetzung dahinter steht, also einfach keine wilde Zerstörung, kein verschlüsseln der Rechner, um Leute zu erpressen oder auch eben kein Sammeln von Informationen, mit denen man halt Betrug machen kann. Rechnungen, die man dann dem Namen des Opfers verschickt, um einfach Rechnungsbetrug zu machen oder dass man eben auch nicht einen Trojaner installiert, eben einfach darauf wartet, dass man eine Bankwebsite aufruft, sondern dass es eben wirklich wahrscheinlich einem Spionage-Zweck dient. Das ist natürlich ein bisschen schwierig zu definieren. Es ist eben dann meistens die Nichtanwesenheit von diesen Ideen.
Ich glaube, es handelt sich über Missverständnis. Ich wollte gar nicht so genau wissen, was Computer-Spionage bedeutet, sondern all die Sachen, die du aufgezählt hast, die haben mich jetzt gerade interessiert. Also aus welchem Grund greift man dieses Thema an?
Auch einfach, weil es im Vergleich zu normaler Spionage schrecklich billig ist. Du riskierst niemanden, der in ein fremdes Land geschickt werden muss. Das ist ja auch für Länder schwierig, wenn Leute aus bestimmten Ländern zu uns kommen, dann fallen sie vielleicht auf. Sie müssen erst integriert werden, sie müssen die Sprache lernen, sie müssen einen Grund haben und das ist zum einen natürlich teuer und es ist halt auch sehr, sehr langsam, Spione einzuschleusen. Und das Internet ist praktischerweise immer an. Man kann sozusagen Leute hacken aus der Sicherheit des eigenen Landes ohne praktisch jede Gefährdung. Und wenn man sich nicht allzu dumm anstellt, dann passiert eben auch nichts Schlimmes, aber nicht unbedingt, weil die Aufklärung schlecht ist, sondern weil halt auch viele Leute, also gerade, wenn das jetzt auch an Länder geht, oft gar nicht wissen, wie sie damit eben umgehen sollen. Und das Problem ist ja, wenn dich jemand ausspioniert, dann richtet er ja nur sehr indirekt Schaden an. Der Schaden kommt ja dann erst später. Und damit ist es natürlich für manche Leute das Problem dann oft sehr, sehr abstrakt. Also auch wenn dir jemand irgendwelche Kenntnisse über deine Produktionsverfahren klaut, dann muss er natürlich das Produktionsverfahren erst mal anwenden. Das muss funktionieren. Und das Einzige, was du dann merkst, ist, dass er dich langsam, aber sicher aus einem Markt drängt. Das heißt, dann ist oft der Zusammenhang zwischen dem Hackerangriff und dem Schaden, der passiert, der ist dann eben einfach nicht da.
Jetzt hast du sozusagen noch mal sehr genau erläutert, was Spielage ist. Aber ich würde das Thema heute auch wirklich ein bisschen weiter fassen wollen, im Sinne von, was du als erstes gesagt hast, dass man irgendwie dieses Thema angreift, um Festplatten zu verschlüsseln oder um Dinge aus Seiten. Das ist dann auch von Interesse. Also wenn wir heute über Attribution reden, also rauszufinden, wer war da in meinem System? Wollte ich jetzt erst noch mal fragen, was gibt es denn alles für Gründe, in einem System zu sein? Und jetzt wissen wir schon ganz ausführlich sozusagen, warum es die Spionagegründe sind. Und dann hast du jetzt kurz sozusagen, als du aufgezählt hast, was es alles nicht war, also wenn es nicht Spionage war, das interessiert mich noch mal, was gibt es noch für Gründe, in Systeme reinzugehen?
Geld verdienen, also letztlich finanziellen Gewinn da rauszuziehen, in der einen oder anderen Form.
Ja, ich wollte noch einen Punkt hinzufügen, wenn wir schon auch von politischen Zielen reden. Das ist natürlich auch ganz klar Sabotage. Also tatsächlich Schäden anrichten in anderen Ländern. Da gibt es auch prominente Beispiele, wo das schon geschehen ist.
Also was es ja auch gibt, vielleicht ganz kurz, einfach um andere Leute zu nerven, DDoS-Angriffe auf Minecraft-Server war doch voll das Ding, oder? Würde das eurer Meinung nach nicht unter Cyberangriff fallen? Also ich in meiner Definition werde es schon da noch mit drinnen, dieses ganz Low-Level teilweise auch, DDoSen und solche Sachen. Genau, halt eine ganz andere Art von Cyberangriff. Aber ja, würde ich auch mit reingehen.
Wobei damit auch Geld verdient werden kann. Also offensichtlich hinter Minecraft-Servern scheint manchmal ziemlich viel Wut zu stecken. Und dann bieten das eben Leute einfach an, für Geld andere Leute Minecraft-Server lahmzulegen und werden dann tatsächlich dafür bezahlt.
Die Schlechtigkeit der Menschen kennt keine Grenzen.
Genau, also die wirtschaftlichen Motive sind extrem mannigfaltig. Das eine ist der klassische DDoS-Pressungsversuch. Du musst uns jetzt keine Ahnung, drei Bitcoins, 10.000 Euro oder sonst was geben. Oder dein Minecraft-Server ist halt fünf Tage down. Oder deine Webseite, wo du einen Webshop hast oder sonst was. Und im schlimmsten Fall ist es auch so was wie Ransomware. Da hatten wir auch schon angesprochen. Das ist auch wieder das klassische finanzielle Motiv. Wir verschlüsseln dir deine Daten. Du kriegst die nur zurück, wenn du Geld bezahlst. Also viel Erpressung, solche Dinge. Aber natürlich gibt es auch noch andere Geschäftsmodelle, wie wir klauen dir deine Daten. Und es ist uns egal, ob du ein Backup hast, weil wir haben jetzt auch eine Kopie von deinen Daten. Wir veröffentlichen die, wenn du uns kein Geld gibst. Also Erpressung ist ein ganz, ganz häufiges Motiv auch.
Macht man eigentlich, also jetzt auch in eurer Arbeit, einen Unterschied zwischen, das ist ein Angriff, der hatte es ganz konkret auf dieses Ziel abgesehen und das ist sozusagen mit der Shotgun oder mit dem großen Schleppnetz durchgeführt worden. Also diese Ransomware-Attacken, also eine Software ist auf meinem Rechner, verschlüsselt alles, ich soll irgendwas bezahlen. Da wird ja meistens, also in vielen Fällen wird ja nicht gezielt jemand angegriffen, sondern das wird einfach gestreut und wer drauf reinfällt, den hat es halt erwischt. Ist das für euch in der Arbeit ein Unterschied?
Ja, also diese, was man da als APTs bezeichnet, das ist ja eben meistens gezielt und steht eben, hat auch eben, dann gibt es natürlich ein konkretes Interesse der Täter, dem Ziel gegenüber. Und bei Ransomware ist ja tatsächlich das Ziel völlig beliebig. Auch wenn das vielleicht dieselben Methoden sind. Und das Problem bei gezielten Angriffen ist, dass es da ja auch andere Risiken gibt. Also wenn mich jemand mit Ransomware verschlüsselt, dann arbeitet er immer nach einem bestimmten Schema, veröffentlicht meine Daten, um mich halt noch mehr unter Druck zu setzen, aber ansonsten will der nichts von mir. Der Spion hat aber ja das Interesse meistens aufgrund von irgendeinem übergeordneten Problem. Und bei dem besteht natürlich das Risiko, dass wenn das mit den Computern nicht funktioniert, dass er sich entweder was anderes ausdenkt oder eben auch andere Methoden schon laufen. Und da stellt sich natürlich die Frage, ist der Spion, arbeitet er wahrscheinlich auf irgendeine politische Veränderung hin, beziehungsweise sein Auftraggeber. Und da ist natürlich schon extrem wichtig, wie sieht die Veränderung aus? Denn selbst wenn man dann Opfer ist, wenn man das Ziel kennt, dann kann man eventuell vorhersagen, was der Spion eben vorhat und darauf entsprechend reagieren. Und bei Ransomware ist ja eigentlich das eigentliche Ziel, dass wenn man das in irgendeiner Form überstanden hat, dann will man einfach nur nicht mal Ransomware-Opfer werden. Aber es besteht eigentlich keine Gefahr, dass der Täter mal persönlich vorbeikommt und beginnt eben die Kasse leer zu räumen.
Technisch gesehen gibt es da, finde ich, auch noch einen interessanten, wichtigen Punkt. Und zwar ist so eine Ransomware, die so ein breit Schleppnetzverfahren oder mit der Shotgun, wie du es so sagt schön formuliert hast, verfahren genutzter Angriff, der ist üblicherweise technisch nicht so gezielt und weit entwickelt und kompliziert oder ähnliches, wie ein ganz, ganz gezielter Angriff, der wirklich auf ein Ziel zugeschnitten ist, wo vorher noch Informationen über das Ziel extra gesammelt wurden und wirklich versucht wird, die Phishing-E-Mail zum Beispiel sehr besonders gut zu gestalten oder vielleicht noch jemand anderes vorher zu hacken, um von den anderen Unternehmen Informationen zu sammeln, um sich besser ausgeben zu können als einen legitimen Kontakt und dann die Malware einzuschmuggeln oder ähnliches. Also da wird üblicherweise mehr Energie reingesteckt, die Methoden sind pfiffiger und auch die technischen Werkzeuge, die benutzt werden, sind etwas exklusiver. Also wenn man sich so ein Arsenal eines Angreifers anschaut, der hat natürlich zum Beispiel Sachen, die hat quasi jeder in seinem Arsenal, die kann man jederzeit benutzen. Und dann gibt es so ein paar Waffen in so einem Arsenal, Cyberwaffen, wie man heutzutage auch gerne sagt, die sind selten. Und immer wenn man sie benutzt, geht man das Risiko ein, dass jemand anderes sie analysiert, entdeckt, veröffentlicht und diese Waffe dann unwirksam gemacht wird, weil jemand Gegenmittel entwickelt. Das kann dann zum Beispiel der Sicherheitspatch sein, der ein gewisses Tool dann außer Kraft setzt, weil es eben eine Sicherheitslücke ausgenutzt hat. Solche Exploits, diese Cyberwaffen, die werden dann eher von einem APT angewendet und sind dann was Neues, was man vorher noch gar nicht gesehen hat, als wenn es der Ransom-Werfischer ist, der hunderttausende Rechner zusammen gleichzeitig angreift.
Ich will noch kurz das Wort ungetümmte Cyberwaffe ein bisschen genauer definiert haben. Frage, bezeichnest du damit das Konglomerat aus? Jemand kennt eine Sicherheitslücke in ein System oder in eine Software, die noch niemand anders kennt und hat dafür auch eine anwendbare Software geschrieben, die man benutzen kann?
Ja, genau. Also das Wichtige ist, dass man spricht immer von einem Proof of Concept oder einem Exploit, der irgendwie eine Sicherheitslücke ausnutzt. Da ist ein interessanter Punkt, weil in dem Moment, wo ein Sicherheitsforscher zum Beispiel eine Sicherheitslücke findet, dann startet er einmal den Windows-Taschenrechner als Demo und sagt, guck, ich kann Code auf deinem Rechner ausführen. Und dass der Windows-Taschenrechner aufpoppt, ist mein Beweis. Und der Sicherheitsforscher geht dann zu dem Hersteller und sagt, fix das mal und hört dort auf. So, und Angreifer jetzt, die sagen, ah, jetzt fangen wir mal an und schreiben jetzt noch ein Tool, das tatsächlich dann mich auf dem Rechner fest installiert, dass ich noch eine Backdoor habe, um da auf einem anderen Kanal nochmal wieder raufzukommen, falls mein Hauptangegriff weg dort entdeckt wird. Jetzt schiebe ich da noch ein Tool, um Daten rauszuholen, mit drauf und so fort. Und dann spricht man von einer Cyberwaffe, weil es nicht nur der erste Schritt ist, das Ausnutzen, sondern auch dann der Lücke, der Sicherheitslücke, sondern auch dann der Schritt, irgendwie tatsächlich als Angreifer tätig zu werden.
Ich habe wahnsinnige Probleme mit dem Begriff Cyberwaffe, vielleicht Vollkorn, vielleicht hast du das gerade auch ironisch verwendet, ich weiß es nicht. Aus journalistischer Perspektive würde ich sagen, dass ich zumindest in der Berichterstattung, die wir haben, so gut es geht, auf dieses Wort verzichte. Es gibt Ausnahmesituationen. Wenn ich sagen würde, der Angriff auf die iranische Atomenanlage in Natanz, Stuxnet, vielleicht würde das klassifizieren, was man als Waffe bezeichnet. Aber ansonsten ist eine Waffe für mich etwas, was eine letale, tödliche Wirkung haben kann. Und das meiste, worüber wir reden, ist einfach Software und Exploits, ist nochmal ein Unterschied für mich.
Das stimmt tatsächlich. Also ich habe jetzt tatsächlich Cyberwaffe benutzt. Das kann auch vielleicht daran liegen, dass ich gerade mich mit öffentlichen Materialien der Regierung auseinandergesetzt habe. Ich habe jetzt gerade den Namen der Organisation vergessen. Da gibt es ja in Deutschland sehr, sehr viele, die sich mit solchen Themen beschäftigen. Und die haben tatsächlich das Wort Cyberwaffe benutzt, auch für Systeme, die dann tatsächlich Schaden anrichten sollen, wenn sie am Zielort angekommen sind, nämlich zum Beispiel ein Stromnetz abschalten in einem Zielland oder ähnliches. Oder eine Fabrik angreifen sollen, ähnlich wie Stuxnet, dass dann die Fabrik explodiert zum Beispiel. Das ist tatsächlich da, wo man die Cyberwaffe benutzt.
Also dahinter steckt eine interessante sozusagen philosophische Diskussion fast schon, weil ich würde einen Pfefferspray auch als Waffe bezeichnen, auch wenn es nicht grundlegend letal ist. Und dann die Frage, inwieweit ist das eine Software oder nicht. Ich möchte aber das gerne weiterhin noch mal über die Kommunikation von Attribution und generell diesem Themenkomplex digitale Angriff reden. Ich wollte jetzt erstmal noch mal bei den Tätern bleiben, also jetzt wissen wir sozusagen, was passieren kann. Oder können wir ja wieder zurückkehren zum Bundestagshack. Hakan, ihr habt ja zu recherchieren versucht und erzählt diese Geschichte in eurem Podcast, wie man herausgefunden hat, wer es gewesen sein soll. Ich konjunktiviere jetzt mal, wir können noch mal nachher darüber sprechen. Und dann ist ja die Frage, ok, da ist also irgendwie ein Rechnersystem des Bundestags oder des Parlaments gehackt worden. Ist dann der Verdacht sofort, das muss ein staatlicher Akteur sein? Oder denkt man erstmal, ja meine Güte, irgendwie technische Systeme, da kann ja einfach mal jemand reinfallen auch, da gehen ja manchmal Sachen kaputt.
Erstens, die Bundestagsverwaltung, als sie das mitbekommen hat, hat das als normalen Fall betrachtet. So wie das halt öfter passiert, es gibt Tausende Trojaner auch im Parlament, irgendwelche Banking-Trojaner und so weiter, die fallen halt auf. Und dann sagt halt die Bundestagsverwaltung, wir tauschen einfach den Rechner aus und gut ist. Und so wurde das am Anfang klassifiziert. Wenn man von der anderen Seite guckt, die Leute, die den Verfassungsschutz gewarnt haben, das war eine Firma aus Großbritannien und die hat festgestellt, dass über eine bestimmte IP-Adresse, dass dort ein C2-Server ist, ein Command-Control-Server, also ein Server, über den die Hacker, die Angreifer ihren Angriff steuern und haben dann von diesem Server, weil sie Kontakte haben zu den jeweiligen Behörden in diesem Land, die ein forensisches Abbild bekommen, ein Image, wo sie dann schauen konnten, die Log-Dateien, wer verbindet sich mit diesem Rechner. Und sie wussten, dieser C2-Server, weil sie die Gruppe seit Längerem beobachtet haben, dieser C2-Server hängt mit der Gruppe APT28, Fancy Bear, Sophosy, halt ist alles, viele Namen eine Gruppe, hängt damit zusammen. Und als sie dann gesehen haben, die Verbindungen kommen unter anderem auch aus dem Bundestag, als die dann beim Verfassungsschutz angerufen haben, war für beide Seiten sofort klar, das muss ein staatlich gesteuerte Angriff sein, weil es ist diese Gruppe und diese Gruppe verorten wir im nachrichtendienstlichen Umfeld.
Aber das ist ja dann schon wieder der spannende Teil der Geschichte, aber das heißt ganz am Anfang, das finde ich jetzt auch nicht uninteressant, da passiert erstmal was auf einem System, was man schon als sehr kritisch bezeichnen würde, nämlich die Infrastruktur unseres Parlaments. Und dann ist das aber erst mal was ganz Normales. Und erst durch den sozusagen durch eine weitere Analyse oder erst eigentlich erst, weil man auf der Gegenseite schon mithören kann, wird klar, dass da möglicherweise was anderes hinschneckt. Und dann wieder die Runde über Wolpertwo und Vollkorn. Wie ist es denn, wenn ihr arbeitet und dann passieren was? Hat man da vom also ihr kommt hin, ihr werdet angefragt, hier bei uns im System ist was nicht in Ordnung. Hat man dann sofort ein Gefühl, einen Verdacht, in welche Richtung das gehen könnte? Oder ist das zuerst nicht so sehr ein wer ist das jetzt, sondern was ist eigentlich das Problem?
Ich glaube, das kommt drauf an. Es gibt bestimmte Ziele, wenn sich dort eben ein Opfer meldet, da ist einfach relativ früh klar, wer daran überhaupt Interesse haben kann. Also es gibt ja auch nicht unendlich viele Hacker und die müssen sich ihre Zeit irgendwie einteilen. Und wenn das jetzt beispielsweise politische Ziele sind, wie letztlich eine Organisation wie der Bundestag oder vielleicht bestimmte Behörden, dann ist natürlich es sehr wahrscheinlich, dass es sich, wenn sich nicht rausstellt, dass Kriminelle falsch abgebogen sind, dass es dann eben ein gezielter Angriff ist. Und es gibt natürlich auch Ziele, wo die Wahrscheinlichkeit, also wie zum Beispiel beim Bundestag, sehr hoch ist, dass sie ohnehin wahrscheinlich eventuell sogar im Visier von mehreren Spionagegruppen sind. Und dann kann das natürlich auch die Zuordnung eine Weile dauern. Da muss man vielleicht dazu sagen, dass sich das mit der Zeit auch verändert, weil eben Täter mittlerweile sehr viel mehr freie Werkzeuge oder Raubkopien von kostenpflichtigen Werkzeugen zur Verfügung stehen, sodass sie gar nicht mehr so sehr darauf angewiesen sind, ihre eigenen typischen Werkzeuge, die wieder ihre Handschrift haben, verraten. Also da hat sich in den sechs Jahren von dem Bundestagstext einiges getan. Aber wenn man jetzt nicht jemanden hat, wo man eigentlich dann sofort sagt, Moment mal, nur X kann sich für Y interessieren, dann ist das erst mal Ergebnis offen und vor allem auch am Anfang. Es ist ganz typisch, dass eben Hektik ist, Chaos. Da sind eben viele Informationen auch falsch. Leute können sich bei der Weitergabe von Sachen wie E-Mail-Adressen, sie können sich vertippt haben. Es sind vielleicht mündlich Sachen besprochen worden, die gar nicht so stimmen. Also meistens ist dann da auch so ein gewisser Chaos-Faktor da. Und das muss sich dann erst mal beruhigen, bevor man das näher sagen kann. Aber natürlich gibt es auch Täter, die eine so typische Handschrift haben oder so auffällige Eigenheiten, dass es dann sein kann, dass die Attribution sehr schnell funktioniert. Da muss man leider sagen, da ist jeder Fall wirklich anders.
Aber ich versuche mal, zwischen den Zeilen zu lesen. Das heißt, schon sozusagen ausgehend von dem, wer betroffen ist, hast du sozusagen einen Standardverdacht oder eine Standard-Einstellung, wo man dann hinterher gucken muss, ob es stimmt. Also wenn es jemand ist, wo es naheliegt, dass man Feinde hat, sag ich jetzt mal platt, dann geht man erst mal davon aus, dann ist es möglicherweise was anderes. Und wenn es sozusagen ein Computer in der öffentlichen Bibliothek ist, dann denkt man, naja, gut, wer weiß, was da passiert ist. Da müssen wir jetzt erst mal nicht davon ausgehen, dass er gezielt angegriffen wird. Was mich noch auch interessieren würde, ist, wenn man lange genug Chaosradio macht, verliert man den Glauben daran, dass digitale Geräte sicher sind. Und jetzt freut mich aber trotzdem, gibt es Systeme, und da gehört der Bundestag offensichtlich nicht dazu, wenn die Bundestagsverwaltung erst mal davon ausgegangen ist, naja, wir tauschen den Rechner aus, es kann ja mal passieren. Aber gibt es Systeme, die so sicher sind, so zu, könnte man vielleicht sagen, dass man sagt, ok, wenn da drin was passiert, dann muss es ein gezielter Angriff gewesen sein.
Oh, da fällt mir das, also ich erzähl mal, das Beispiel, das wir schon vom Namen angesprochen haben, Stuxnet, ist, glaube ich, ein interessantes Beispiel in der Stelle, weil die sind ja nicht, das ist ein Angriff gewesen auf eine Uran-Anreicherungsanlage. Und da sind sie ja nicht übers Internet gegangen, sondern sie sind darüber gegangen, dass sie tatsächlich USB-Sticks auf den Parkplatz gelegt haben und Leute dann da hingegangen sind und den USB-Stick mitgenommen haben vom Parkplatz und in den Rechner gesteckt haben, um zu gucken, was ist denn da drauf. Und das ist zum Beispiel so ein Fall, wo ich sage, das ist eine Anlage, da ist der Angriffsweg nicht übers Internet möglich gewesen. Die ist abgeschottet wohl. Und da ist dann natürlich der Verdacht, wenn man dort etwas entdeckt, dass es nicht ein Ransomware-Fall, ganz klassisch ist, sehr viel näherliegend, als wenn das irgendein Rechner ist, der mit dem Internet verbunden ist und E-Mails empfangen kann und ähnliches.
Ja, das ist eigentlich ein extrem gutes Beispiel. Also man kann Netze abschotten, wenn man das von außen beurteilen kann, wie der Bundestag natürlich massiv von Kommunikation abhängen. Also den Abgeordneten E-Mails zu verbieten, das wird wahrscheinlich nicht gut funktionieren. Aber Produktionsanlagen oder alles, was letztlich halt nicht davon abhängig ist, dass eben permanent Daten mit dem Internet ausgetauscht werden müssen, wie zum Beispiel ein industrieller Prozess, wo sich auch manchmal über Jahre nicht so viel ändern muss. Solche Netze, die können manchmal ganz gut abgeschottet werden, wobei man leider dazu sagen muss, dass in der Industrie oft das Geld eben dafür nicht bereitgestellt wird, weil das ist dann natürlich viel Handarbeit. Und da muss natürlich, das sind Netze, die sind für einen, für eine Ransomware-Game, also für jemanden, der Erpressungstrojaner ausbringt, die sind für den uninteressant, weil vielleicht gibt es da Leute, die die Fähigkeiten haben, aber da ist ihnen der Aufwand zu hoch. Die wollen ja einfach Geld verdienen. Und wenn dann wirklich jemand ernsthaft die Hürden überwunden muss oder sich beispielsweise merkt, dass er gar nicht mit freien Standardwerkzeugen arbeiten kann, dann schränkt das die Täter, die das machen, eben massiv ein. Und hoher Aufwand bedeutet ja auch hohe Kosten. Irgendjemand muss das ja auch sozusagen genehmigen. Und dann wird sozusagen die Hürde, das zu tun, immer höher. Und dann ist es irgendwann auch sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass einfach, ich sag's mal so, Alltagskriminelle dort auftreten. Aber ich glaube, da ist wirklich stutzend, wie Vollkorn gesagt hat, echt das beste Beispiel für.
Aber lektionlich daraus lernen ist, ist ein System am Netz, ist es im Prinzip auch dran?
Also natürlich kann man auch unterschiedlich sichere Systeme am Netz haben. Ich meine, wir haben jetzt gerade zum Beispiel immer noch ein aktuelles Problem mit Outlook-Servern, die im Internet sind und eine seit vielen Monaten bekannte Sicherheitslücke haben, die dazu führen kann, dass man sie ohne Anmeldung, soweit ich gerade weiß, von außen übernehmen kann. Und wir haben immer noch, ich glaube, 8 oder 10 Prozent der Outlook-Server in Deutschland sind immer noch nicht dagegen gepatcht. Das heißt also, natürlich gibt es einfach viele Unternehmen, die sind da einfach nicht hinterher.
Na gut, aber das ist die Frage, gibt es Systeme, die im Netz sind, die leicht angreifbar sind? Da ist der Antwort, ja. Ich wollte ja umgedreht sagen, gibt es Systeme, die am Internet hängen, wo ihr trotzdem sagt, die sind aber so sicher, das muss gezielt gewesen sein? Oder ist es so, sobald ein System am Netz hängt, kann es eigentlich immer auch Ziel einer Streu-Fischerei-Attacke gewesen worden sein?
Das ist ein bisschen schwierig zu beantworten. Es kommt wirklich, also in einer gewissen Form, es kommt ein bisschen darauf an, wie offen dein System sein muss. Also wenn du dein System ans Internet hängst und du tust nichts, außer sozusagen passiv zu surfen und stellst eben keine Inhalte bereit und man weiß beispielsweise gar nicht, wo du gerne hin surfst, dann wird das schon schwierig. Ich würde mal sagen, man könnte das so formulieren, wenn das System am Netz hängt und man hat eben gut ausgebildete und motivierte Leute, die auch Zeit haben, um das System zu pflegen. Dann kann auch so ein System eben schwer zu knacken sein. Wenn wir jetzt beispielsweise hier dein Beispiel Vollkorn weiterspielen, die Exchange oder Outlook Server, wenn man da eine gute Truppe hat, dann kann die auch ein Problem, das sie nicht verhindern kann, nämlich, dass das Produkt eine Schwäche hat, die eben Microsoft verursacht hat und das ist ja geschlossener Code, da kann man nichts ändern. Dann können die das eben kompensieren und zum Beispiel sehr schnell drauf reagieren. Also es braucht eigentlich immer zwei Dinge. Es braucht eben ein System am Netz und es braucht eben irgendwelche Defizite in der Betreuung aus guten oder schlechten Gründen und dann natürlich, also was dann das Schlagwort wäre im Englischen, ist dann immer, wovon die Leute sprechen, ist die Attack Surface. Also tatsächlich die Zahl der Dienste, die es anbietet und was es alles machen muss. Und da könnte man vielleicht sagen, wenn das System sehr viele Dienste anbieten muss, wenn es mit allen möglichen Dingen kommunizieren wird, dann ist es natürlich irgendwann eben genauso, wie du sagst, dann ist einfach die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass da irgendwas doch kaputt ist und dass da nur jemand reinkommt, sehr hoch.
Ja, und ein Faktor, den ich da auch noch reinbringen möchte, ist, wie viele Menschen arbeiten mit diesem System? Ist das ein System, das zum Großteil für sich selber arbeitet? So eine Industrieanlage hat ein paar Bedienpersonal vielleicht. Ich stelle mir solche Systeme wie das Tollcollect vor, mit dem die Straßenzölle für LKWs in Deutschland gesammelt werden. Das sind zum Großteil automatisierte Systeme, die Informationen sammeln und an zentrale Server leiten. Aber da sind nicht so viele Operateure dran, wie zum Beispiel in einem Bundestag, wo man unglaublich viele Leute hat, die mit diesem System tagtäglich die ganze Zeit arbeiten. Denn ganz viele der Angriffe gehen immer wieder darüber, dass man versucht, eine der Personen, die an diesem System arbeitet, zu überzeugen, etwas zu tun, was sie eigentlich nicht tun sollte. Dieses eine Programm ausführen, das per E-Mail zugeschickt wurde.
Okay, dann können wir sozusagen tatsächlich zu dem Punkt jetzt übergehen. Hakan hat es schon ein paar Mal erwähnt, den Begriff Spearfishing-Mails. Hakan, kannst du kurz erklären, was da passiert ist?
Sehr gerne. Was passiert ist, ist, dass an, ich glaube, 50, bitte nicht auf die Zahl fest nageln, Leute angeschrieben wurden. Und eine dieser Personen, die diese E-Mail bekommen hat, hat uns dann auch erzählt, was es für eine E-Mail war. Es war konkret, muss man sich noch mal vorstellen, die Zeit 2014 rum die Krim wird besetzt. Es gibt, Ukraine und Russland befinden sich in einem Konflikt, der in den Krieg ausartet. Die Vereinten Nationen äußern sich mehrfach dazu. Und in dieser Zeit kriegt eine Mitarbeiterin im Abgeordnetenbüro eine E-Mail, in der so getan wird, als ob die E-Mail von den Vereinten Nationen kommt. Und sich zur Krim-Krise äußert. Diese Person saß in den relevanten Ausschüssen drin, zum Beispiel für Menschenrechte. Sie hat dann gesagt, natürlich, auf mich so eine E-Mail. Weil wenn ich später in dieser Sitzung drin bin, und die Leute sagen, wieso kennst du die Position der Vereinten Nationen nicht? Die kamen doch gerade per E-Mail an alle. Dann stehe ich dumm da, jetzt leicht paraphrasiert. Und das ist, was eine Spearfishing-E-Mail besser macht als eine normale Phishing-E-Mail. Du weißt, wem du was schickst, aus welchen Gründen. Und du bist dir sicher, dass diese Person diese E-Mail öffnen wird. Ganz einfache Art von Spearfishing-E-Mail, die jetzt nicht besonders ausgeklügelt ist, wenn du deine Bewerbung an Human Resources schickst, das ist einfach deren Job, Bewerbungen zu öffnen. Wenn du einem Journalisten oder einer Journalistin schreibst, hey, hier ist ein Tipp, bitte öffne das Word-Dokument, ich habe dir alles zusammengefasst, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass der oder die Journalistin das einfach öffnen wird, etwas höher. Und je besser du bist, desto gezielter ist dieses Spearfishing auch.
So, und dann ist was, nee, andersherum sozusagen, also dieser eine erste Schritt oder ein Exemplar für diesen ersten Schritt. Vollkorn, Wolpertwo, habt ihr da noch andere? Oder ist das genau das Ding, ich hab schon erzählt, irgendwie US-Besticks auf dem Parkplatz verlieren. Das hört sich ja alles schon sehr Spionage-mäßig an.
Ja, also ich glaube, so wie Hakan das beschrieben hat, da würde man sagen, also beispielsweise, dass das Human Resources, also eine Personalabteilung, bleiben wir mal dabei, dass die Lebensläufe öffnen müssen, das ist eben Alltagswissen. Das ist dann, also das kann eben auch ein intelligenter Täter herausfinden, der, also der beispielsweise nicht Deutsch oder nicht ähnlich spricht, auch ohne da groß was über das deutsche Unternehmen zu wissen, da reicht eben das Google Translate aus. Was Hakan beschrieben hat, da würde man dann einfach sagen, das ist ein Spearfishing, das stinkt eben schon nach Nachrichtendienst, das ist eben, also es ist eben einfach zu schlau. Da weiß jemand genau, aha, das ist eben offensichtlich hier eine Person, auf die das genau zugeschnitten wird und der weiß, dass dann im Vorfeld, wenn er das richtig baut, eine Öffnungsabsicht dieser E-Mail besteht und das ist dann irgendetwas, da gehört etwas dazu. Da muss ich nicht wissen, wie man das Spearfishing macht, sondern ich muss inhaltliche Dinge über den Bundestag wissen, wie da gearbeitet wird, wie die Ausschüsse funktionieren, um diese E-Mail zu backen und das ist eben nicht der Job eines Hackers und das hört sich dann eben wirklich stark danach an, dass dann eben dort Nachrichtendienste unterwegs sind.
Gibt es noch andere?
Da wird aber vielleicht noch eine Anmerkung. Die ganz ordinäre cyberkriminellen Gruppierungen, die fangen natürlich langsam auch an, mit solchen Methoden zu arbeiten, weil sie festgestellt haben, wie effektiv das ist. Emotet hatte zum Beispiel, es ist so eine Schadsoftware-Botnet gewesen, das ist durchs BKA, da gab es einen Takedown, die wurden runtergenommen, aber die haben auch meinen Rechner gehackt und klinken sich dann in eine laufende E-Mail-Kommunikation ein zwischen mir und euch, meinetwegen, und packen da ihre Nachricht rein. Und das hat mit APT, mit dem staatlichen Spionage-Aspekt, überhaupt nichts zu tun, aber ist eine wunderbare, effektive Methode, um die Leute dazu zu bringen, die Schadsoftware zu installieren, weil sie genau dieses menschliche, dieses psychologische Element vollkommen ausnutzen an der Stelle.
Jetzt bin ich gerade ein bisschen verwirrt, weil wenn man sich so ein bisschen mit, also wenn man das nur, wenn man Security sozusagen verfolgt am Rande, dann sind immer so Horrormeldungen wie, es reicht, wenn du die falsche Webseite aufrufst, es reicht, wenn die falsche E-Mail in deinem Postfach ist. Alles, was ihr erzählt, ist eher so in die Richtung, man muss die Leute schon dazu bringen, wenigstens einmal eine Datei anzuklicken. Wie ist es denn nun?
Also ich würde gerne noch zwei Beispiele reinbringen, die das vielleicht ein bisschen noch verbreitern, die mir auch schon beruflich begegnet sind. Ein Beispiel ist, ein Dienstleister eines Unternehmens wird gehackt. Und dieser Dienstleister hat zum Beispiel Zugang zu deinem Netzwerk, weil der, weiß ich nicht, der betreut dann irgendwelche Server bei dir in deinem Netzwerk und dann wird dieser Zugang, der beim Dienstleister gefunden wird, ausgenutzt. Da kann man sich quasi kaum schützen, denn der Dienstleister muss diesen Zugang ja bekommen, sonst kann er seinen Dienst nicht ausführen. Da braucht auch auf der Seite des Opfers niemand irgendwo an der Datei öffnen oder was anklicken oder sonst was machen. Da lässt man einfach das System laufen und wird Opfer. Und ein anderes Beispiel, das natürlich auch ganz häufig ist, ist, was wir auch schon angeschnitten haben, dass ein Patch nicht eingespielt wurde für irgendein System und dann tatsächlich eine Sicherheitslücke, die bekannt ist, einfach ausgenutzt wird. Und da kann die Sicherheitslücke tatsächlich auch so gravierend sein, dass überhaupt gar keine Interaktion mit irgendeinem Benutzer nötig ist, sondern einfach nur dadurch, dass der Rechner läuft und am Internet angeschlossen ist, angegriffen werden kann.
Was es auch noch gibt, vielleicht sind sogenannte Waterholing-Angriffe, dass du halt auf einer Webseite, wo du weißt, dass Leute da hingehen werden, weil sie es für den Job machen müssen oder wie auch immer, dass sobald du dort auf diese Webseite surfst, die unsurfst, dann läuft der Exploit und dann ist dein System infiziert. Das haben mutmaßlich nordkoreanische Hacker gemacht, die gezielt IT-Sicherheitsexperten angestiegen haben, die haben eine Webseite besucht und dann wurde in dem Browser, Chrome war das, glaube ich, ist einfach ein Exploit, der wurde dann exploitet und die waren dann auf den Systemen sozusagen drauf. Sowas gibt es auch.
Und das ändert sich natürlich auch immer dadurch ein bisschen, dass die allermeisten kriminellen Hacker, die schauen sich ja ihre Methoden ab. Also die wollen ja nur Geld verdienen, die wollen nicht irgendjemand beeindrucken. Und vor einiger Zeit, da war auch, glaube ich, mal ein Vortrag auf dem Kongress zu dem zu dem Blackhole Exploit Kit und mittlerweile scheinen diese Exploit Kits, also sozusagen Webseiten, die dann ein bisschen prüfen können, welche Verwundbarkeiten hat der Browser und dann die passende auswählen, um dann den Rechner anzugreifen, die Schadsoftware unterzubringen. Das scheint jetzt dann doch erheblich zurückgegangen sein. Und gerade scheint dann eben wirklich auch sehr beliebt zu sein, halt dann einfach verschiedene Dokumente mit Makros zu verschicken und sozusagen das Opfer einfach zu bitten, die Makros wieder einzuschalten. Das hängt auch immer so ein bisschen von den Jahren an, wo man gerade guckt. Also es gibt auch immer beliebte Methoden, die gerade sehr gut funktionieren, zum Beispiel, weil halt auch viel kriminelle Infrastruktur getrimmt ist. Aber auch, also ich glaube, die Eltern unter uns, die damit nicht so viele anfangen können, müssen sich da keine Gedanken machen. Eine Gruppe, mit der ich jetzt über zehnmal zu tun hatte, da hat sich der Angriff nur ein einziges Mal auf eine Fishing-Mail zurückführen lassen. Ansonsten war das das gute alte Hecken von Systemen im Internet und sich davon einfach weiter hangern. Ich glaube, Fishing ist halt deswegen so beliebt, weil es so universell ist. Also wenn jetzt ein Spion ein Ziel in Peru hat, ein Ziel in den Philippinen, dann kann er davon ausgehen, die werden ja schon irgendwie mit E-Mail arbeiten oder meine Opferrechner sind wahrscheinlich nahe an Rechnern, wo mit E-Mail gearbeitet wird. Das ist dann eben einfach eine sehr universelle Methode, aber es ist eben bei weitem nicht die einzige wie die Beispiele von Hakan und Vollkorn, die wir gerade gezeigt haben.
So, also das hört sich alles schon wieder so furchtbar an, dass man denkt, man will jetzt seine Rechner verbrennen und dann, nein, Entschuldigung, umweltgerecht entsorgen und dann lieber was mit Holz und Orchideen machen. Aber das ist man nicht. Also der Bundestagshack war also eine Sache, die schon speziell war in dem Sinne von was das Ziel war, aber technisch von dem, was ich jetzt gelernt habe, nicht im Bereich des Unmöglichen. Wie, also vielleicht alle drei als Hakan, dann die anderen beiden, wie ist denn im Nachhinein so die Beurteilung dieses Haks aus technischer Perspektive? War das, also vom Ziel her, ja es war etwas Besonderes. Vom Effekt her, ja es war es was Besonderes. Aber einfach die technische Handwerksarbeit, die da passiert ist. War das was Besonderes oder war das einfach sehr, naja, für das Ziel hätte man es halt einfach so gemacht, da war kein Hexenwerk dabei.
Also ich kann oder ich würde da die Expertise von Vollkorn und Wolpertwo an der Stelle abwarten. Und genau eine Sache, die ich sagen will oder zwei Sachen. Erstens, ich habe im Anschluss an den Hack zwei Jahre später ein Stück vom Quellcode bekommen von APT28, diese Hackergruppe. Und den hatte ich damals Andreas Bogh gezeigt und der hatte sich das angeschaut. Also der ein oder andere könnte Andreas Bogh kennen von den HörerInnen und der hat gemeint, ja der Code tut genau das, was er tun soll. Es ist nicht der schönste Code unter der Erde, aber passt schon. Und so, bei dieser Hackergruppe wurde das von IT-Sicherheits-ExpertInnen uns auch so erklärt, die sagen, APT28 hat eine ganz klare Art und Weise, wie sie in Netzwerke reingehen und es sieht dann so aus wie, das haben sie Smash-and-Grab-Einstellungen genannt. Die gehen rein, machen in kurzer Zeit alles platt, es ist vollkommen wurscht, ob sie auffallen oder nicht. Also das ist jetzt nicht so die super Vorsichtige, bloß nicht im Lichtkegel unterwegs sein, damit wir nicht auffallen, sondern die gehen rein, holen sich was sie brauchen und gehen raus, ist, was mir gesagt wurde von den Leuten, die so Forensik betreiben.
Vollkorn, Wolpertwo, würdet ihr sagen, da ist jetzt sozusagen was ganz Besonderes passiert, oder waren das klassische Kriminelle? Also gute schon, die verstehen ihr Handwerk, aber...
Ja, also meine Einschätzung ist, das ist tatsächlich ein für die Gruppe sehr typischer Angriff gewesen. Man kennt diese Gruppe durch viele andere Angriffe, die sie durchgeführt haben. Ja, man weiß, die haben ihre eigens entwickelten Werkzeuge. Das, was der Hakan da auch gerade eben ansprach, wo er den Quellcode von da mal gesehen hat. Und die Werkzeuge, die hat nicht jeder, die hat die Gruppe selber gebaut. Und da haben sie auch ziemlich viele Ressourcen, also Personal, die das gebaut haben. Da steckt viel Erfahrung über Jahre drin, aus vielen Angriffen, die die schon gemacht haben. Das heißt, ich würde sagen, das ist auf jeden Fall vom Level her über der klassischen Ransomware-Truppe, die irgendwo reingeht. Aber es ist nicht der übelst krasse, besonders hervorstechende Heck der Gruppe jetzt gewesen.
Etwas, was Hakan ganz am Anfang gesagt hat, dass nämlich der C2 Server bereits unter Beobachtung stand, das spricht ja dafür, dass letztlich nicht jemand per Zufall diesen C2 Server gefunden hat, sondern der wurde ja wohl, so wie Hakan das beschrieben hat, identifiziert, weil damit andere Ziege angegriffen wurden. Das heißt also, diese Täter haben eine Infrastruktur gegen unterschiedliche Ziele verwendet und das machen sie ja wahrscheinlich nicht, weil ihnen langweilig war, sondern weil sie skalieren mussten. Und soweit ich weiß, also russische Spionage ist nicht so ganz meine Ecke, ist gerade diese Truppe dafür bekannt, dass sie eben sozusagen im Zweifel zwei schnell zur Verfügung steht und eben besonders viele Angriffe sehr zackig machen kann. Also ein Angreifer, der eben wie Vollkorn das auch ein bisschen beschrieben hat, der eben so schon ein gewisses Konzept hat, mit dem er eben arbeitet. Und dann hat eben das Konzept gegen den Bundestag funktioniert, was eben heißt, dass die Sicherheit vom Bundestag genauso gut oder genauso schlecht war, wie eben das von allen anderen Opfern auch. Und das spricht dann eben auch dafür, dass es sich um aus der Perspektive der Täter sehr wahrscheinlich um den Alltagsauftrag gehandelt hat. Was jetzt natürlich interessant ist, warum hat das jemand beauftragt? Also warum hat jemand eine Gruppe, die eben dafür bekannt ist, eben aufgrund der Skalierung, die sie leisten muss, Kompromisse bei ihrer operativen Sicherheit zu machen? Warum hat jemand diese Gruppe auf den Bundestag angesetzt? Weil im Endeffekt ist es ja halt dann doch rausgekommen. Und soweit ich weiß, gibt es da natürlich auch in Russland Gruppen, die da auch um einiges vorsichtiger sein können, die eben natürlich nicht die gleiche Infrastruktur gegen mehrere Ziele verwenden. Vielleicht haben wir auch unter unseren Zuhörern Leute, die dann jetzt schon irgendwie Anfängerfehler gebrummelt haben.
Wer weiß. Aber dann kommen wir jetzt zur eigentlichen Frage. Jetzt ist ja der Spoiler schon gefallen, die Russen waren es. Aber wie kommt man da hin? Also woher weiß man das? Ich würde es jetzt umdrehen, zu sagen, Hakan kann gleich erzählen, was er gelernt hat, darüber, wie man das beim Bundestag herkommt, weiß. Aber wenn, also Wolpertwo, du hast ja zum Beispiel gerade erzählt, du bist da mit einer Gruppe zu Ganger, die sind jetzt irgendwie zehnmal über den Weg gelaufen. Woran erkennt man Typen, Gruppierungen, EinzeltäterInnen vielleicht? Weil letztlich ist doch Code digital 0 und 1.
Oh Gott, also da kommen ganz viele Faktoren zusammen. Im Internet veröffentlicht, also in den öffentlichen Berichten sind ja oft Sachen beispielsweise auch drin, die jetzt derjenige, das veröffentlicht, auch manchmal für ein bisschen harmlos hält. Also vielleicht nur IP-Adressen und Prüfzummen. Aber letztlich ist es so, dass also zum einen ein Malware-Analyst würde natürlich auch beispielsweise sagen, dass der Code von Angreifern sich oft erähnet, dass sie hier natürlich auch Kompromisse machen und Sachen natürlich gerne wieder verwenden. Weil, also wie gesagt, sie kriegen ja nichts dafür, dass ihre Vektor besonders schön und einzigartig ist. Sie kriegen was dafür, wenn sie Ergebnisse produzieren. Und da gibt es dann eben auch sozusagen Skalierungsmethoden. Und insgesamt sind das eigentlich die Skalierungsmethoden, die sich unterscheiden, weil es gibt auch sicher Sachen, die sind beliebig. Die eine Gruppe, die entscheidet sich eben dafür, die andere dafür. Aber im Endeffekt kriegst du dann eben eine Handschrift, die besteht eben aus der Art, wie die Internetinfrastruktur aufgebaut wird, aus der Art, wie die Tools benannt sind. Und teilweise auch, also wo sich auch Leute immer drüber lächerlich machen, aber das ist tatsächlich interessant, zu welchen Uhrzeiten die Leute arbeiten, ob sie einen Schichtbetrieb haben, ob sie besonders diszipliniert sind und wirklich genau nur das machen. Was sie offensichtlich tun sollen oder ob sie eben sehr schlampig arbeiten. Oder aber manche Angreifer, die machen auch manchmal seltsames Zeug, was man eigentlich erst verstehen würde, wenn man mit diesen Leuten mal spricht und dann herausfindet, was es eigentlich werden soll, was es fertig ist. Das sind wirklich über die Zeit sehr, sehr viele Faktoren, nicht nur einer. Und wahrscheinlich hat auch jeder, der sich Gruppen anguckt, auch so ein bisschen seine Lieblingsfaktoren.
Ja, ich finde den Punkt, den Wolpertwo gerade zum Letzten angesprochen hat, die über die Zeit sehr wichtig, weil man erkennt tatsächlich viele Angriffe wieder, weil sie wieder das gleiche Muster, das ein vorheriger Angriff hatte, wieder zeigen oder zumindest sehr ähnlich sind und stellt dann die Parallelen her. Und dann baut man so langsam einen Corpus an Wissen auf, der immer größer wird. Mit jedem Angriff, den die machen, mit jedem Update der Malware, die dann gefunden wird, wird also ein besseres Bild von dieser Gruppe klar. Und ganz viel dieser Attribution läuft tatsächlich darüber, dass man sagt, guck mal, das haben wir doch schon mal bei dem Angriff gesehen, wir können jetzt diese Verbindung hier herstellen. Und an einem dieser Angriffe stellt man dann mal eine Verbindung zu Russland fest und sagt, ah ja, okay, dann ist also diese ganze Angriffgruppe mit diesen 20 Angriffen, die wir beobachtet haben, vermutlich eine russische Gruppe. Und das sind natürlich viele, viele Indizien, die keine wirklich handfesten Beweise sind, also sowas wie die Uhrzeiten, zu denen die arbeiten. Aber wenn man dann feststellt, das ist wirklich immer so der Fall, dass die immer nur zu Büroöffnungszeiten, Moskauer Zeit arbeiten, dann verhärtet sich natürlich der Eindruck, dass es ein russisches Team ist und nicht irgendjemand in den USA, der immer nachts arbeitet. Also ganz viel sammeln über die Jahre hinweg und immer wieder verknüpfen von verschiedenen Angriffen und Mustern, die man gesehen hat, zu einem großen Bild.
Naja, aber. Also das Schöne am Digitalen ist ja, wenn man es kopiert, ist es nicht unterscheidbar. Also keine Ahnung, wo war das denn irgendwie? Zum ersten Mal bin ich damit überhören bekommen beim Adressen, wie heißt es, Mac-Adressen-Spoofing, weil man WLANs kann man einstellen, dass nur bestimmte Netzwerkkarten, die eindeutige Identifizierer haben, reinlassen und diese Mac-Adressen zu fälschen, ist aber etwas, was man seinen Kindern als Entwicklungsaufgabe stellen kann, aber nicht eine ernstzunehmende Sicherheitsvorkehrung. Und wenn wir uns jetzt schon in dem Bereich Spionage bewegen, also Leute greifen gezielt unter Aufwendung großer Mittel, also Spearfishing-E-Mails an und sind bekannt, wie belastbar ist denn die Information? Wenn man dann sagt, naja, das habe ich schon 19 Mal gesehen, das müssen also die sein, weil, wie gesagt, wir sind eh schon im Bereich Spionage, ist ja nicht die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass jemand hinkommt und sagt so, ja, Moment mal, wenn wir jetzt da reingehen und gar nicht wollen, dass irgendwie überhaupt der Antwort, dann lass uns doch einfach so benehmen, wie diese komischen, wie ist es, APT 28. Also, Punkt.
Kann ich da direkt, es gibt eine wieder mutmaßlich russische Gruppe, ich verspreche hoch und heilig, dass ich auch nicht mutmaßlich russische Gruppen als Beispiel anbringen werde, sobald sie mir einfallen, aber es gibt eine, die Thurla genannt wird und die hat eine andere APT Gruppe imitiert und die sollte eben, oder sie hat sich, sie hat Infrastruktur einer mutmaßlich iranischen Gruppe verwendet, was genauso ein bisschen dieses Beispiel, so ein Beispiel ist für das, was du gerade gesagt hast. Die machen genau das und es war dann halt das, was du klassischerweise Force-Flag-Koperation nennst. Sowas gibt es natürlich. Aber der Aspekt, der glaube ich wichtig ist und den sowohl Vollkorn als auch Wolpertwo angesprochen haben ist, als Hacker-Gruppe hast du ja das Problem, hast du zwei Probleme. Erstens, du weißt nicht, auf welchem Punkt die anderen die Muster erkennen. Bei Apti 28 kam es irgendwann 2014, 2015 raus. Die Gruppe agiert seit 2004. Deswegen musst du und das ist das zweite Problem, du musst quasi etwas über die Dauer der Zeit machen, wohl wissen, dass die Hacker in der Verteidigung immer besser werden und irgendwann irgendein Muster finden, das sich über die Jahre hinweg durchzieht. Du gehst den Datenbanken zurück, die zehn Jahre zurückreichen und siehst dann plötzlich, hey, das haben die schon damals gemacht und plötzlich hast du ein Puzzlestück, mit dem du sehr, sehr viele Gruppen attributieren kannst. Deswegen ist diese Zeitdauer auch noch wichtig. So wird es immer wieder mir erklärt und das finde ich eigentlich auch sehr, sehr plausibel tatsächlich.
Ich finde, du hast da absolut recht, Marcus. Und zwar ist das wirklich keine exakte Wissenschaft mit Attributierung. Und das Beispiel von Hakan ist auch super, mit der Gruppe, die eine andere imitiert. Es gibt natürlich auch richtig professionelle Faults-Flag-Operationen. Ein schönes Beispiel ist da die CIA. Auf Wikileaks gab es die sogenannten Vault-7-Leaks. Da wurden CIA-Hacking-Tools geleakt. Und eins dieser Tools nennt sich Umbridge. Das ist tatsächlich ein Stück Software, das versucht, explizit eine Malware so zu manipulieren, dass sie aussieht, als ob sie von einer bestimmten Gruppe kommt. Also die haben wirklich sich hingesetzt und gesagt, wie können wir denn jetzt diese Faults-Flag-Operationen zum Programm machen, dass wir in täglichen Operationen einsetzen können? Also das ist durchaus ein Ziel, das auch verfolgt wird, offensichtlich von den Geheimdiensten. Und es gibt einen Menschen, der heißt Jake Williams, der ist bei der amerikanischen NSA gewesen, der Taylor Access Operations. Die sind auch sehr bekannt geworden durch Snowden, diese Abteilung. Das ist tatsächlich die Abteilung, die ganz maßgeschneiderte Angriffe auf bestimmte Ziele durchgeführt hat. Und der ist da also drin gewesen in dieser Abteilung und ist dort ausgetreten und erzählt dann auch recht offen darüber, was dort getan wurde und wie sie gearbeitet haben. Und der erzählt auch, dass sie tatsächlich durchaus so eine False Flag Operations durchgeführt haben. Und ganz häufig ist das Ziel nicht unbedingt zu verschleiern, wer genau man ist, weil tatsächlich ist das auch sehr schwierig. Man muss mich aufpassen, also es ist möglich, auf jeden Fall. Aber man darf keine Fehler machen, denn wenn man Fehler macht und man plötzlich irgendwie doch mal wieder seine richtige IP-Adresse angibt und versehentlich seinen richtigen Namen irgendwo eingibt, wenn man einen Server mietet oder sowas, dann gibt es wieder eine Verbindung. Aber dadurch, dass man viele falsche Informationen streut, wird es unglaublich schwierig für eine Person, die das versucht zu analysieren, zu entscheiden, was ist jetzt echte Information und was ist gestreute, falsche Information. Und wie kann ich das unterscheiden? Und welche Information ist die, die ich jetzt zusammenziehe zu meinem Gesamtbild und sage, die waren es? Und diese Unsicherheit alleine reicht schon aus, um so eine Attribution sehr schwierig zu machen oder am Ende vielleicht sogar wertlos oder vielleicht auch einfach nur so lange zu verzögern, bis die Reaktion der Angegriffenen einfach schon zu spät ist, weil das eigentliche Angriffsziel schon längst erreicht wurde.
Apropos Angriffsziel, jetzt frage ich mich gerade, warum macht man diese Aufklärungsarbeit überhaupt? Also klar, aus einer strafrechtlichen Perspektive kann ich das verstehen, oder aus diplomatisch-politischen. Aber jetzt, ihr beiden als Technikexperten, also technisch stelle ich mir zumindest vor, geht es ja erst mal darum, wenn sowas passiert ist, das System wieder sicher zu machen und die Lücken zu stopfen, durch die man reingekommen ist. Gibt es einen technischen Grund, rausfinden zu wollen, wer das ist? Also ist nicht aus der technischen Perspektive eigentlich immer nur interessant, was ist da passiert?
Also das eine ist, um rauszufinden, wer das ist, ist ganz einfach, weil man faul ist. Man möchte sozusagen möglichst schnell den Angriff aufklären, Zugangspunkte, Ausgangspunkte finden. Und wenn ich weiß, wer das ist, dann kann ich gezielter suchen, dann brauche ich nicht so lange. Das ist also auch einfach, das ist dann halt die Skalierung auf der Seite des Verteidigers. Und zum anderen ist es bei manchen Sachen auch Pflicht, weil sozusagen nicht für alle Opfer besteht ausglücklich ein finanzieller Schaden. Also wenn manche Leute ausspioniert werden und wenn die international reisen, wenn sie zu bestimmten Nationen oder Bevölkerungsgruppen gehören, wenn sie ausspioniert werden, dann ist das ja auch eine Absichtserklärung des Staats dahinter und die ist in gar keinem Fall positiv. Das heißt, man muss natürlich einen Spionageopfer auch darüber informieren, wer hier die möglichen Täter sind, dass es sich auch überlegen kann, okay, passieren denn in der richtigen Welt Dinge, die mich beeinträchtigen? Jetzt natürlich bei Corona ist es irrelevant, aber beispielsweise wird man beim Zoll immer aufgehalten, wird man von Sicherheitskräften schuriegelt, kann man Notebooks, wenn man irgendwo unterwegs ist, wirklich nicht im Hotel lassen, weil sie dann immer Kratzer haben oder komische Dinge passieren. Das gehört eben dazu. Also in vielen Fällen ist es natürlich so, dass Spionage, also Einspion kommt selten allein und die können natürlich auch andere Methoden eben einsetzen, und dann ist es natürlich wirklich sehr wichtig, dem Opfer Bescheid zu sagen, dass es eben auch mal gucken kann, okay, wie komme ich denn jetzt mit der Gesamtsituation klar?
Ein kleiner Randaspekt auch, also es gibt ja neuerdings auch Versicherungen für Unternehmen, IT-Versicherungen, die in Fällen von Schäden durch Angriffe über das Internet einspringen sollen und die haben natürlich auch bestimmte Sachen, wo sie sagen, dagegen versichern wir und andere Sachen, wo sie nicht dagegen versichern. Und da kann es natürlich auch eine sehr wichtige Frage sein, ob die Versicherung jetzt einspringt und den entstandenen Schaden zum Beispiel ersetzt, ob das jetzt ein Staat war, der dort einen Angriff durchgeführt hat oder nicht. Weil vielleicht sind Spionageangriffe eben nicht von der Versicherungspolizei abgedeckt. Also es gibt da durchaus auch solche Randaspekte, wo das dann wieder sehr spannend werden kann.
Das ist ja die Frage. Aber ab wann gilt denn so ein Ergebnis als sicher? Das ist ja dann auch spannend. Also wenn ich euch richtig verstanden habe, ist dadurch, dass das Ganze digital ist, könnt ihr, wie soll ich das sagen, also gerichtsfest, vielleicht können wir das Wort benutzen, also von dem, was ihr erzählt habt, habe ich das Gefühl, wenn ihr euch so was begegnet, dann könnt ihr irgendwann sozusagen mit der Sicherheit des Experten, der sich im Feld bewegt, eine recht zuverlässige Mutmaßung darüber anstellen, wer das möglicherweise gewesen sein könnte. Aber ist das dann sozusagen gerichtsfest? Also könnte man da mit jemanden verknacken?
Also ich glaube, da muss man einmal sich kurz klarmachen, nach welchen Prämissen und Prinzipien zum Beispiel Nachrichtendienste arbeiten und nach welchen Ermittlern, die Polizei und so weiter, nach welchen die arbeitet. Für den Nachrichtendienst geht es nicht darum, etwas gerichtsfest klarzumachen. Die Nachrichtendienst hat andere Aufgaben. Der muss aufklären, der muss sagen, nach unserem Dafürhalten passiert XYZ, da läuft eine Operation. Die wird statt dem manntwegen Russland, USA, Israel, wie auch immer zugewiesen. Und wir sagen das mit einer Wahrscheinlichkeit von so und so viel Prozent. Diese Prozentzahlen sind bei Nachrichtendiensten fast schon so hard codiert mit, wie sicher etwas ist. Wenn sie sagen 95 bis 99 Prozent, dann ist das das Maximale, was man von denen bekommen wird. Mehr haben die nicht, mehr wollen die auch nicht. Und damit sie an diesen Punkt kommen können, ist es selten der Fall, ich habe hin und wieder mit solchen Leuten geredet, aus europäischen Nachrichtendiensten oder generell westlichen, die gesagt haben, pass auf, wir verlassen uns nie nur auf technische Indizien, wir haben auch Signals Intelligence, das heißt, wir schauen, was die Hacker machen, indem wir sie hacken oder wir haben Human Intelligence, das heißt, wir haben Quellen vor Ort, die uns gewisse Sachen anderweitig bestätigt haben. Und dann haben sie so einen ganzen Baukasten an Prinzipien, nach denen sie am Ende sagen, wie sicher sind wir uns? Eine kriminalistisch arbeitende Behörde wie das Bundeskriminalamt, die wird natürlich sagen, was sind unsere rechtsstaatlichen Prinzipien? Die funktionieren so, dass wir am Ende sagen müssen, hier ist die Tat, hier ist der Täter. Und die müssen dann zum Staatsanwalt und der Staatsanwalt geht damit zum Richter und der Richter unterzeichnet das dann oder nicht. Und das ist das, was wir rechtsstaatlich nennen. Und genau, und in solchen Fällen kann ich sagen, ist es gerichtsfest ab der Sekunde, wo es halt zu einem Verfahren kommt und diese Person verurteilt würde.
Aber das klingt für mich schon mal so, dass die das jetzt sagen, also allein aus dem, was Täter in einem System hinterlassen oder was man ihnen sagen nachführen kann, lässt sich das nicht so sicher sagen. Und was mich jetzt noch sozusagen bei Vollkorn und Wolpertwo interessieren würde, ist, Hakan hat jetzt erklärt, was der Unterschied ist zwischen einer nachrichtendienstlichen Bewertung und einer juristischen Bewertung. Wie ist es denn in der IT-Security? Ich würde tippen eher so, wie die Nachrichtendienste das machen.
Ja, das würde ich auch sagen. Also wenn ich so ein Report schreibe, wo ich sage, wir haben folgende Dinge entdeckt, dann schreiben wir vielleicht noch ein Summary dazu, also eine Kurzzusammenfassung, wo dann sagt, okay, es deutet darauf hin, aber wir sagen eigentlich nie, wir sind uns hundertprozentig sicher. Weil wir führen dann auch üblicherweise an, an welchen Stellen, also wie viel Aussagekraft das hat. Also zum Beispiel haben wir dann immer noch gleich eine Relativierung, die dann sagt, das könnte aber auch ein gefälschtes Indeed sein oder Ähnliches. Also da sind wir auch sehr vorsichtig, weil uns ganz klar ist, zum einen, dass nämlich wir zum Beispiel bei dieser Untersuchung nur einen Ausschnitt der Informationen gefunden haben und andere Informationen einfach übersehen haben, die ein ganz anderes Bild zeichnen würden. Das kann passieren. Es kann sein, wie wir schon besprochen haben, dass da Volts-Flag-Operationen jetzt im Spionagebereich oder aber auch ganz einfache Verschleierungsaktionen, wie zum Beispiel man mietet sich als Angreifer oder Angreiferin einen Server im Ausland, wo man gar nicht sitzt und geht da rüber. Und dann kann man schon wieder ein paar Informationen haben, wo man jetzt nicht weiß, okay, ist das jetzt wirklich dem Angreifer zuzuordnen oder der Angreiferin oder ist das was anderes? Also da muss man schon sehr vorsichtig sein und ganz klar auch sagen, wie viel Aussagekraft die Sachen, die man hat, entdeckt hat, wirklich haben. Und die Antwort ist üblicherweise nichts Exaktes, nichts hundertprozentiges, sondern immer so ein, wir haben recht viele Indizien, die dies sagen, es ist wahrscheinlicher, dass es jenes ist als solches, aber kein festes, das ist es definitiv.
Ich möchte aus den ganzen Merkmalen, die ihr aufgezählt habt, mal eins rausgreifen, das ist nicht dieses, weil du es gerade auch noch mal sagt, das nicht sich einen Server mieten. Also es gibt das Prinzip der IP-Adressen, also Rechner, die im Netz sind, haben eine Nummer, über die man sie identifizieren kann. Und da würde ich ja denken, das ist ja wirklich das allerkleinste Ein-mal-eins, die, wenn ich irgendwo angreife, dass ich natürlich nicht, dass der dann nicht die IP sieht von dem DSL-Anschluss von zu Hause, sondern dass ich dann einen sozusagen einen VPN benutze, also ein Netzwerk, wo ich dann erst mal in ein anderes Land vielleicht sogar gehe. Das heißt, gibt oder was ist die Frage dahinter eigentlich? Ich muss kurz mich zusammenfassen und überlegen. Die Frage dahinter ist, glaube ich, also konkret sind sowas wie IP-Adressen überhaupt von Relevanz bei den Ermittlungen und ein bisschen weitergefasst. Gibt es mittlerweile digitale Dinge, von denen man sagt, also ja, die könnten theoretisch ein Merkmal sein, aber die sind einfach so leicht zu fälschen, das müssen wir uns nicht mal angucken.
Ich komme mir vor, wie ein Rechtsbelehrungspodcast. Also beispielsweise, wenn man gerade auch mit Leuten, die eben solche Angriffe simulieren, was so auf Neudeutsch-Recht-Team-Angriffe redet oder halt auch mit Leuten auf der Offensive kommt oder so, die beschweren sich auch immer darüber, dass sie halt irgendwie skalieren müssen, dass sie ihre Internetinfrastruktur pflegen müssen. Und wenn dann natürlich Täter einen Opfer mit letztlich derselben Software, derselben Infrastruktur angreifen, dann kann natürlich die IP-Adresse sehr viel wert sein, wenn man es mit Profis zu tun hat, die wirklich probieren, was dann wieder das nächste Schlagwort wäre, Compartmentalization, die dann halt wirklich probieren, für jeden eine eigene Verwertungskette bestehend aus Werkzeugen, aus Internetinfrastruktur aufzubauen. Dann sind natürlich die IP-Adressen weniger wert. Aber das Schöne ist auch, wenn Angreifer erfolgreich sind einmal, dann machen ihre Chefs nun mehr Druck, dass sie mehr Erfolg haben und dann müssen sie nur noch mehr skalieren. Das heißt also, es gibt immer so paar Merkmale, wo dann halt Täter sagen, dass sie dann eben auch Kompromisse machen oder aber, weil sie auch, wenn sie aufgeklärt haben, werden gar kein Risiko befürchten, weil sie gar nicht vorhaben, ihr Land zu verlassen. Dann spielen natürlich IP-Adressen, Prüf-Summen eben immer noch eine Rolle. Sie sind halt heutzutage vielleicht ein bisschen weniger übertragbar geworden, weil halt die meisten Täter halt mittlerweile wissen, wie sie ihre Melker so schreiben, dass die halt jedes Mal eine andere Prüf-Summe hat. Aber auch der eine oder andere wird auch sagen, okay, ich greife Ziele an, die sind so schlecht gesichert, da mache ich mir die Mühe ja nicht. Und von daher, ja, ich glaube, das Problem heutzutage besteht immer darin, wenn die Täter halt Zugriff auf entweder Open Source Hacking Software haben oder auch einfach Raubkopien und dann einfach alle dieselben Werkzeuge verwenden. Dann kann man natürlich mit der Tatsache, dass der Täter das Werkzeug X verwendet, kann man nichts anfangen, wenn das schlichtweg alle anderen auch machen. Und das ist auch sehr angenehm für die Täter, weil dann können sie sich vor als Flag-Operationen sparen.
Eine Anmerkung vielleicht noch auf IP-Adressen bezogen unter diesen Leuten, die in dem Bereich Forensik und Threat Intelligence, also herausfinden, wer hinter diesem Angriff steckt, gibt es diese Pyramid of Pain, was im Wesentlichen bedeutet, wie schwer, wie einfach ist es und wie wertvoll sind manche Informationen. Und IP-Adressen sind relativ weit unten, weil sie vergleichsweise wertlos sind. Aber je weiter du zur Spitze dieser Pyramide kommst, dann geht es plötzlich um diese Tools, die du einsetzt. Und um ein Beispiel zu nennen dieser russischen Gruppierung, die ich genannt hatte, Tula, was die machen ist, die haben ihre ausgespähten Daten teilweise über Satelliten abgestrahlt. Und das kannst du einfach nicht fälschen, weil es nur gewisse Nationen gibt, die die Fähigkeiten haben, Daten über Satelliten abzustrahlen und aufzufangen und dann vor Ort zu entschlüsseln. Dann ist natürlich klar, das muss eine nachrichtendienstliche Behörde sein, ob das dann wirklich diese Gruppe war, sei mal dahingestellt. Aber alleine durch die Tools, die man wählt, gibt man sich auch ein Stück weit Preis. Wenn jetzt alle sagen, wir verwenden nur noch Cobalt Strike, was so ein Angriffswerkzeug ist, das auch sehr viel als Robokopie eingesetzt wird oder gecrackt, dann kann man es nicht mehr machen, weil es alle einsetzen.
Also ein Aspekt auf der anderen Seite ist bei einer IP-Adresse zum Beispiel, die ist zwar für so eine Attributierung wertlos, aber in so einer forensischen Analyse kann das schon wieder ein sehr interessantes Merkmal sein, weil wenn man eine IP-Adresse hat, von der man weiß, von hier aus ging jetzt ein Angriff auf das System, das ich mir gerade anschaue, dann suche ich doch mal in all den Log-Dateien meines Systems, ob ich die IP-Adresse noch finde. Dann ist das nämlich ein sogenannter Indicator of Compromise und der hilft einem super, dann wieder weiter sich aufzufächern und weiter zu gucken, wo denn noch diese Angreifer oder Angreiferinnen gewesen sein könnte in meinem System. Oder ich könnte die auch veröffentlichen und sagen, hey Leute, guckt doch alle mal, habt ihr von dieser IP-Adresse irgendwelche komischen Pakete empfangen? Guckt doch mal da rein. Also, das hilft mir wenig bei der Attribution direkt, aber es ist ein gutes Merkmal, um weiter zu suchen, was denn noch alles irgendwo gewesen sein könnte.
Okay, also kann mir sozusagen tatsächlich ein bisschen bei der Aufarbeitung helfen. Jetzt haben wir das abstrakte und theoretisch besprochene Hakan. Also, ihr habt den ganzen Podcast zugemacht, aber kannst du kurz zusammenfassen, welcher Fehler oder welche Dinge dazu geführt haben, dass man sich da, ich formuliere es mal nachrichtendienstlich, relativ sicher ist, wer das war?
Kann ich gerne machen. Und zwar einmal etwas, was sehr, glaube ich, vielen Leuten sofort einleuchtet, ist der Hacker, um den es geht. Der hat Google Mail verwendet, was ich persönlich bis heute einfach crazy finde, aber so war das anscheinend. Und über Google Mail kommen halt die amerikanischen Behörden und sagen, hey, Google, gib uns bitte dieses Postfach, hier ist der Richter, der unterschrieben hat, hier ist das Dokument, das du uns bitte übergeben musst. Google übergibt denen das Postfach, sie geben das an die Deutschen weiter später und dann findet man halt da relativ viel über diesen Menschen drin, so wie in euren E-Mail-Accounts auch wahrscheinlich sehr viele persönliche und private Informationen sind. Das war der eine Teil. Und der zweite Teil ist, dass der Typ, in der Chart-Software, die er programmiert hat, hat er vergessen, einen Dateipfad zu löschen. Das ist PDB nennt sich das und das sind im Wesentlichen Debugging-Informationen. Also du schreibst Software und dieses Software, dieses Programm sagt dir, pass auf, in Zeile so und so ist ein Fehler, der dafür sorgt, dass es folgende, dass deine Funktion nicht genau ausgeführt wird. Oder wie auch immer. So eine Hilfestellung für Programmiererinnen. Und in diesem Detailpfad war sein Kürzel enthalten. Also ich weiß nicht, wie eure Rechner heißen. Wenn mein Rechner heißen würde, Hakan's MacBook Pro, würde in diesem Detailpfad stehen, 10 Doppelpunkt, Hakan's MacBook Pro. Und sowas stand bei ihm auch drin. Und dann haben die Mittel halt geguckt, okay, können wir dieses Pseudonym auf eine Person zurückführen über etwas besseres Googlen.
Also, ich bin jetzt ein bisschen überrascht, dass es dann sozusagen so einfach ist. Also ist natürlich nicht, man muss die Software auseinandernehmen und dann reingucken sozusagen. Aber wow, ist das einfach was passiert?
Also Fehler, die passieren, sind tatsächlich die Durchbrüche üblicherweise bei so einer Attributierung. Also wenn man irgendwie dann mal feststellt, ach hier, diese Angriffserver, den wir jetzt gerade identifiziert haben, wer hat den denn angemietet? Und dann guckt man eben nach und stellt fest, wie Hakan schon eben gerade erzählt hat, irgendwie durch juristischen Prozess, hier bitte gib uns die Daten, lieber Anbieter. Oh, da steht ja tatsächlich der Name einer Person drin oder da steht irgendwie eine Behördenadresse aus Moskau drin oder sowas. Dann ist das plötzlich so ein Hinweis, wo man denkt, wow, wie kommen sie da drauf, den hier reinzumachen? Und das sind häufig Fehler, die passieren, weil zum Beispiel Druck da war, weil gedacht wurde, ach, das System, das benutzen wir eigentlich nicht dafür, dann wurde es doch dafür benutzt, irgendwo Kompromisse gemacht wurden, wie Wolpertwo gerade schon mehrfach gesagt hat. Oder irgendwie eine Operation schieflief und mal schnell was eben gemacht werden musste. Und dann sind irgendwie Sachen übersehen worden, die ganz eklatant und offensichtlich sind und gefunden werden.
Ja, und das ist dann eben natürlich auch wieder ein Hinweis dafür, dass es sich eben um jemand handelt, dem das vielleicht gar nicht bewusst war. Und es deutet auch eventuell darauf hin, dass er eventuell gar nicht die Aufsicht oder die Ausbildung gehabt hätte, die ihm gesagt hätte, mach das mal bitte anders. Also das hört sich dann eben wirklich nach etwas an, was maximal auf Skalierung getrimmt wird. Ist ja auch wahrscheinlich so, dass wenn halt direkt oder indirekt der Chef Vladimir Putin ist, dass man ihn nicht mit schöner Mehrwert beeindruckt, sondern eben mit vielen Ergebnissen. Und dass dann eben hier das eher so ist, da wird eben gehackt wie in einem Core-Center. Da laufen eben viele Operationen parallel. Und dann ist dann im Zweifelsfall, wie Vollkorn das gesagt hat, dann ist vielleicht sogar eine permanente Hektik da. Und dann gehen eben solche Sachen schief, weil einfach die Zeit da nicht da ist für die Sorgfalt. Da es ja aber auch irgendwo eine Führung gibt, muss man auch davon ausgehen, dass die Führung so was in Kauf nimmt, dass ihr entweder das Risiko bewusst ist oder es ist ihr nicht bewusst. Es ist so wichtig, den Output zu produzieren, dass das eben komplett in Kauf genommen wird oder untergeht. Also es ist sozusagen dann wirklich eher Supermarkt hacken, als halt irgendwie was Schönes sehr auf das Ziel zugeschnitten ist.
Das klingt nicht schön. Das klingt nicht so, als sollte man für solche Chefs arbeiten. Aber gut, was mich da gerade frage ist, wenn also eine der Hauptgründe, wie man den Leuten auf die Spur kommt, der Stress ist, den sie ausgesetzt sind, was macht man eigentlich, wenn man so jemanden im System findet? Also im Sinne von man findet ein kompromiertes System und will dann unter Umständen wissen, wer das ist. Lässt man den dann noch drin und macht ihm das Leben schwer, um ihm eben Stress auszusetzen oder ist eigentlich die Regel immer, wir machen jetzt zu und dann gucken, was übrig bleibt?
Das kommt, glaube ich, ein bisschen darauf an, wie die Situation aussieht. Man redet da häufig immer von Sichtbarkeit. Wenn man den Täter in einem sehr großen Netz findet und groß ist da schon relativ, also auch 1000 Rechner können ganz schön unübersichtlich sein, dann ist ja zu befürchten, dass das letztlich nur die Spitze des Eisberges ist. Also nehmen wir an, wir haben ein Netz mit irgendwie 1000, 2000 Rechnern. Es gibt vielleicht nicht mal eine große Truppe von Administratoren. Man ist eben auf sozusagen irgendwie externe Services angewiesen, die auch dann beauftragt werden müssen. Also wenn man mal 30 Notebooks braucht, dann passiert das nicht schnell schnell, sondern dann muss erst der externe beauftragt werden. Dann muss er erst vorbeikommen. Dann hat man ein bisschen ein Problem, weil dann weiß man dieses Netz ist wahrscheinlich an sich unsicher und ich habe jetzt den Angreifer zufällig an dieser Stelle gefunden. Und dann kommt es eben ein bisschen auch darauf an, was da gemacht wird. Also kann man aus Betriebsgründen überhaupt abschalten? Also gerade in der Industrie kann man Produktionsprozesse nicht unterbrechen, weil das sind halt relativ große Maschinen, die müssen dann eben durchlaufen. Dann haben die Kunden eben natürlich auch ein Anrecht auf Sachen. Das spielt dann eben alles eine Rolle, wie man handeln kann oder nicht.
Aber die Frage, die ich stelle, ist eigentlich eine strategische. Deswegen lasse ich mich sozusagen für die theoretische Diskussion umformulieren. Wenn ich die Wahl habe, zwischen den Zugang, den die TäterInnen haben, abschneiden oder nicht, mache ich das dann sofort? Oder ist es sozusagen in manchen Fällen eine Validüberlegung, zu sagen, na ja, lass mal gucken, was die noch so anstellen? Oder lass mal den Zugriff irgendwie einengen und gucken, ob sie dann einen Fehler machen.
Also ich kann da ein Beispiel aus der Regierung nennen. 2018 gab es einen Angriff auf das Auswärtige Amt und die haben die erstmal machen lassen. Einerseits lässt du die machen, weil du wissen willst, wo sind die eigentlich noch? Und wenn du das Gefühl hast, dass du sowohl es mir erzählt und auch in einem anderen Hacking-Vorfall, du willst gucken, an welchen Stellen sind die überall in deinem System? Und wenn du das rausgefunden hast, dann kannst du koordiniert, dann schickst du halt den Mitarbeiterinnen eine E-Mail und sagst, bitte setzt mal euer Passwort, ein neues Passwort muss angelegt werden. Oder du sagst, wenn die im Wochenende sind, nimmst du die entsprechenden Clients, Desktop, PCs oder was auch immer, betroffen ist vom System und tauschst die aus und machst einen Clean Cut und schmeißt die Täter auf eine Art und Weise raus, wo du dir im Nachhinein sicher bist, dass du keine Backdoors übersehen hast. Das kann ein Argument sein dafür, dass du sagst, wir beobachten die erst mal. Und das hat Wolpertwo ja angesprochen, damit du eine bessere Sichtbarkeit hast. Wo sind die überall im System?
Ja, ich denke der wichtigste Faktor zur Entscheidung ist, bin ich mir sicher, dass wenn ich sie beobachte und machen lasse, dass sie mir dabei nicht unter meinem Hintern meine wichtigen Daten klauen. Wenn ich mir da sicher sein kann, weil sie jetzt zum Beispiel gerade nur in irgendwelchen unwichtigen Systemen sind, dann kann man das mal durchaus machen und sie beobachten. Aber die viel häufiger und üblichere Strategie, in meiner Erfahrung ist auf jeden Fall zu sagen, wir schalten jetzt alles ab und gucken uns an, was da noch an Spuren übrig sind und sorgen dann dafür, so schnell wie möglich wieder kontrolliert ein neues, abgeschottetes System hochzufahren, das frei ist von diesem Angreifer.
Ich glaube, ein Problem in der Realität ist auch, dass je nachdem, wer da angegriffen wurde, dass man manchmal gar nicht die Wahl hat, diese Entscheidung zu treffen, wenn man ein sehr großes Netz hat. Nehmen wir mal an, völlig aus der Luft gegriffen, irgendwie so 120.000 Systeme. Von denen sind etwa 50.000 bis 60.000 noch Windows 7, irgendwie 10.000 oder 12.000 sind noch Windows XP, weil das halt Produktion ist. Und in der Produktion kann ich nicht hinkommen und ständig den Leuten die Rechner neu installieren, dann werden die wahnsinnig. Und dort muss ich mir dann wirklich gut überlegen, was ich mache, weil im Zweifelsfall, wenn ich eingreife, bevor ich die nötige Sichtbarkeit habe und eben Sicherheitsmaßnahmen schaffen kann, dazu brauche ich Personal, das muss auch irgendwo herkommen oder freigestellt werden, dann schubse ich den Täter ja nur irgendwo anders hin. Also dessen Interesse erlischt er nicht, weil ich seine ersten zehn Rechner abgeschaltet habe, sondern der wird ja eventuell weitermachen, wie er seinen Auftrag erfüllt hat. Und schlimmstenfalls schäuche ich dann den Gegner sozusagen durch mein komplettes Netz und habe ihn dann auf einmal an fünf Stellen statt an einer. Und das ist dann natürlich auch, was eben der Betrachtung wert ist. Wenn jetzt jemand ein sehr kleines, übersichtliches Netz hat, der sagt, hey, am Wochenende, da können wir einfach mal alles abschalten und in zwei Tagen machen wir wirklich Strecke und kriegen ein paar Probleme, die die Angreifer ausgenutzt haben, die kriege ich in zwei Tagen im Griff, weil ich die richtigen Leute habe. Dann ist das auf jeden Fall ein gangbarer Weg. Ein anderes Problem ist natürlich auch, dass man manchmal, wenn man ein sehr großes Netz hat, die Zielsetzung des Täters kennen muss, weil für den ist ja nicht alles interessant. Also sozusagen der Kantinenplan, der würde ihn eher wenig interessieren. Das heißt also, das komplette Netz ab einer gewissen Größe sicher zu machen, ist absolut unmöglich. Wenn jemand ein Horrorbeispiel sucht, dann muss er sich vorstellen, irgendwie CISO, also Sicherheitschef vom Netzwerk des US Departments of Defense zu sein. Das ist das Verteidigungsministerium, die haben ungefähr eine Million Rechner. Und die macht man einfach nicht sicher, die werden nie sicher sein. Und dann ist es eben sinnvoll, den Angreifer zu beobachten, zu sagen, Moment mal, der interessiert sich nur für das. Also dann sichern wir eben diese 300 Systeme. Und im Rest, na wenn da die Wölfe ein paar Schafe reißen, dann ist auch egal, weil es einfach gar nicht realistisch ist, diese große Struktur eben zu schützen. Und letztlich ist es oft so, das Auftragsbuch des Angreifers, das ist wirklich das Allerwertvollste, weil seine Absicht ja auch sagt, was passiert denn nach dem Angriff? Was hat er vor? Und daraus kann man eben halt gezielte Schutzmaßnahmen ableiten, aber auch Kompensationsmechanismen, die einfach gar nichts mit Technik zu tun haben.
Jetzt ist eine Sache, die man noch machen kann. Und das ist auch was, was in dem Podcast ganz am Ende diskutiert wird, der sogenannte Hackback. Also dass man sich nicht damit zufrieden gibt, den Angreifer aus dem eigenen System zu werfen, sondern auch dessen Infrastruktur zu hacken. Und das ist ja, wenn ich es richtig auf dem Schirm habe, ein zumindest kontroverses Thema. Bevor wir über die politischen Implikationen reden, erstmal technisch. Gibt es ein technisch sinnvolles Ding, zu sagen, hey, lass uns doch einfach kaputt machen, was uns kaputt macht? Oder übernehmen, was uns versucht zu übernehmen?
Also versuchen kann man das auf jeden Fall, keine Frage. Das ist allerdings üblicherweise ein langwieriger Prozess. Die meisten Aktionen laufen über einen längeren Zeitraum. Und man hat nicht so dieses, ah, wir werden angegriffen, ich drücke jetzt auf den Knopf und dann greifen wir zurück an Mechanismus. Sondern da muss man erstmal die Attribution sauber machen. Man muss erstmal unglaublich viele Informationen sammeln, wie wir ja schon die ganze Zeit besprochen haben, sich sicher zu sein. Und dann muss man also eine Möglichkeit finden, an diesen Angreifer oder die Angreiferin ranzukommen.
Kurze Zwischenfrage, wenn du sagst, die Attribution sauber machen. Das wundert mich jetzt wiederum, weil ich kann nachvollziehen, dass es schwierig ist, eine Person, also zu sagen, diese Person war es. Aber ich dachte schon, dass es einfach ist zu sagen, okay, von dem System kommt das.
Genau, dann sind wir jetzt direkt bei dem politischen Problem. Wenn wir jetzt nämlich sagen, wir greifen einfach das System an, das uns angreift, dann greifen wir mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit irgendein unbeteiligtes System an, das gemietet wurde oder gehackt wurde oder ähnliches, um den Angriff als Jump-Hose zu nutzen. Also als irgendein System, das nicht dem Angreifer oder der Angreiferin gehört, sondern einfach nur zur Verschleierung benutzt wird, um den Angriff tatsächlich durchzuführen. Also das ist eine ganz simple Methode, die quasi jede Angreifergruppe im Petto hat. Und dann hast du natürlich als jemand, der diesen Hackback durchführt, das Problem, dass du möglicherweise einem dritten Staat, der überhaupt nichts mit der ganzen Situation zu tun hat, auf die Füße trittst. Und das ist ein politisches Fiasco, das du vielleicht nicht haben möchtest.
Vielleicht ein ganz plastisches Beispiel. Eine mutmaßlich nordkoreanische Gruppe, die in Lazarus genannt wird, die unter anderem Rheinmetall gehackt hat. Die hat einen C2 Server gehabt, das war ein Auktionshaus in Italien. Und wenn du jetzt plötzlich gegen dieses Auktionshaus vorgehst, was können die dafür? Ganz blöd gesagt. Deswegen glaube ich, dass dieses ganze System übernehmen, das funktioniert schon, weil Hackern passieren einfach Fehler, wie ganz normalen WordPress-Block-Admins-Fehler passieren. Die lassen teilweise ihre Webseiten auf und dann kann man die Logs sehen. Man kann verschiedene Shard-Software auseinandernehmen und gucken, wie genau kommuniziert die. Und wenn du ein Nachrichtendienst bist, dann weißt du, ich fingerprinte diese Kommunikation und dann weißt du, von welchen Servern das kommt. Und da bist du schon relativ weit fortgeschritten im grundsätzlichen Verständnis davon. Und das ist, glaube ich, eine Entwicklung, über die man auch offen und ehrlich diskutieren muss und auch transparent diskutieren muss, dass immer mehr Staaten dazu anfangen, dieses ganze digitale Raum, dieses Fähre, dieses Cyberraum sozusagen als permanenten Konfliktzustand betrachten. Das steht bei den USA, glaube ich, auch explizit so in der Strategie drin. Persistent Engagement oder Defending Forward oder wie auch immer, dass dann der korrekte Begriff ist. Das passiert die ganze Zeit. Willst du oder wollen wir als Deutschland an der Stelle da mitspielen, ist eine Diskussion, die geführt wird. Ich glaube, man kann Argumente dafür finden, aber ich sehe auch das Argument, dass Leute sagen, hey, Deutschland ist, vielleicht lacht jetzt der ein oder die andere, aber trotz allem schon vergleichsweise digital. Und machen wir uns damit nicht selbst, schießen uns damit nicht selbst ins Knie, weil sollten wir nicht lieber diese Systeme erst mal sichern, bevor wir hier anderen die Systeme kaputt schießen.
Das ist ein wichtiger Aspekt, den du da ansprichst, aber gar nicht hinten mich auch. Eine Angriffstrategie, so ein Hackback ist ja ein Angriff auch. Die hat immer eine Folge, nämlich, dass man sich Angriffswerkzeuge irgendwie sammeln muss. Und so ein ganz klassisches Angriffswerkzeug, das ist der sogenannte Zero Day, das wurde sicherlich auch schon öfters im Chaosradio erwähnt, eine Sicherheitslücke, die noch nicht öffentlich bekannt ist. Und diese Sicherheitslücke kann man benutzen, um Angriffe durchzuführen, weil es dafür keinen Patch existiert, der sie absichern könnte. Aber wenn jetzt eine solche Sicherheitslücke entdeckt wird, wäre es ja eigentlich viel sinnvoller, wenn wir sagen würden, wir machen das bekannt dem Hersteller, zum Beispiel Microsoft, wenn es in Windows ist oder so was, und die können einen Patch installieren, bauen und diesen austeilen auf alle Systeme. Dann ist mit dem nächsten Update, sind dann alle Systeme sicher, also viele Systeme sicher, nicht jeder spielt ja im Update ein, aber dann haben wir insgesamt eine Welt, auf der alle Systeme sicherer sind. Aber wenn wir jetzt sagen, wir wollen eine Angriffsstrategie fahren, dann wäre es vielleicht ja auch klüger, diese Sicherheitslücke zu suchen, sie aber nicht den Hersteller zu melden und für sich zu behalten, die ganzen Systeme im Netz unsicher zu lassen und diesen Vorteil für sich zu horten. Und das finde ich natürlich eine fatale Strategie für uns alle. Das ist nämlich eine sehr egozentrische Strategie, die eben nicht die Sicherheit des gesamten Internets berücksichtigt und aller Bürger, die das Internet nutzen weltweit. Darum bin ich auch auf jeden Fall der Meinung von Hakan, dass eine defensive Strategie auf jeden Fall die bessere Strategie ist. Die verhindert mich einerseits, dass wir angegriffen werden können und andererseits verbessern wir dadurch auch noch möglicherweise die gesamte Stabilität des Internets.
Ich will kurz auch noch, wenn ich darf, ein Gegenargument bringen. Also Spionat für einen Nachrichtendienst, der hat eine andere Aufgabe. Die Sicherheit des Internets ist jetzt nichts, was im Kriterienkatalog des Bundesnachrichtendienstes stehen würde. Die haben die Aufgabe, Informationen zu beschaffen. Und man kann argumentieren, dass man den BND nicht haben will, dann ist es eine andere Sache. Aber wenn man sagt, wir haben so einen Dienst, dann wird der natürlich Sicherheitslücken ausnutzen, um an diese Informationen zu kommen. Es hat auch Bruno Kahl in diesen Sitzungen im Parlamentarischen Kontrollgremium gesagt, da gibt es jedes Jahr eine, die öffentlich ist, dass sie in, ich glaube Zitat, dass sie fremde Strukturen aufklären. Und Spionage hat auch einfach einen Sinn und Zweck, wenn man sagt, man will in Verhandlungen wissen, was die Gegenseite, was ihr eigentliches Ziel ist, um festzustellen, wo die Puffer sind, wo man nachverhandeln kann, dann ist Spionage ein etabliertes, praktisches Verfahren in der internationalen Politik. Und um dieses Gegenargument zu Ende zu führen, wieso sollte das im digitalen Raum nicht gelten? Wieso sollte man das nicht machen dürfen? So kann man das auch sehen, so kann man auch argumentieren, finde ich.
Aber da ist doch derselbe Blindschluss, der immer, wenn sozusagen solche Konzepte vom Analogen ins Digitale übertragen werden, da ist. Nämlich, das Digitale ist halt ein On-Off-Schalter. Also, wenn man sagt, also, in einem Podcast ist das sehr schön beschrieben, höre ich es an, ne? Also, da sieht man Leute, die sagen, na ja, Spionage, ältestes Gewerbe der Welt, das macht man halt so in der Politik. Meine Güte, stell dir mal nicht so an. Das ist sozusagen, was ich da gehört habe. Und das kann man natürlich sagen. Aber jetzt ist natürlich, ne, also wenn James Bond sich den Bart anklebt und in die Botschaft geht und dann in den Marktenkoffer stöbert, dann passiert halt genau das. Wenn wir aber sagen, die digitalen Werkzeuge, um das zu machen, müssten zur Verfügung gestellt werden, passiert genau das, was Vollkorn gesagt hat, dann sind es nämlich, dann sind alle Opfer. Nicht nur die, die das Spiel spielen, sondern alle Menschen. Und das finde ich echt sehr, sehr kurz gedacht. Und mir macht ein bisschen Angst, dass das sozusagen in dieser Verkürzung noch an diesem Punkt, also beim Kontroltreber so gebracht wird.
Ja, das ist auch einer der Gründe, warum eine wichtige Forderung des Chaos Computer Clubs ist, dass das Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik, das BSI hier in Deutschland, das eben auch ganz klar als Aufgabe hat, sich um die Sicherheit von Informationssystemen zu kümmern. Ich meine, das steht im Namen, ne? Dass die eben nicht dem Bundesministerium des Inneren für Inneres unterstellt sind, sein sollen. Denn das Bundesministerium für Inneren hat natürlich da einen Interessenkonflikt. Die haben da andere Vorstellungen, was zum Beispiel Verteidigung nach außen oder Ähnliches angeht als reine Absicherung und reine Defensive Technik. Und wenn die nämlich abhängig wären, dann könnten wir sicherer sein, dass wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel eine Sicherheitslücke melden und da irgendwie das BSI einbeziehen, dass die nicht versuchen, diese Sicherheitslücke unter den Druck ihres Mutterbundesministeriums unter den Tisch zu kehren oder den Teppich zu kehren und für irgendwelche anderen Zwecke zu gebrauchen.
Also das macht es BSI auch nicht, soweit ich weiß. Nur BSI, alles was denen gemeldet wird, wird in diesen Coordinated Disclosure Prozess eingeleitet. Das explizite ist, was macht der Bundesnachrichtendienst, wenn er eine Sicherheitslücke findet, muss er die sofort preisgeben? Und ich kenne die Position des CCC. Ich will nur darauf hinweisen, dass es nicht deren Aufgabe ist. Man kann das komisch finden und schlecht finden, aber es ist nicht deren Aufgabe.
Also die Lektion ist sozusagen, solange wir einen BND haben, haben wir auch Sicherheitslücken, die nicht an die Öffentlichkeit kommen, weil wir einen BND haben.
Das ist deren Originär, das ist eine Klasse, aufzuklären und die werden die Tools verwenden, die ihnen dabei helfen. Man kann natürlich darüber diskutieren, dass man denen sagt, wie es in den USA ist, dass man denen sagt, wenn ihr eine Lücke habt, dann hat die eine Haltbarkeitsdauer, die könnte nicht von heute bis ins Unendliche horten. Irgendwann müsste das wieder Preis geben, das kann man diskutieren, aber wenn der BND irgendwas machen soll, dann wird er das natürlich auch über Sicherheitslücken machen, nicht ausschließlich, da darf ich auch Internetverkehr filtern usw. Kann man alles kritisieren, aber es ist einfach originäre Aufgabe des BND. Das ist alles, was ich sagen will.
Also, kompliziertes Thema, wo man nichts richtig sagen kann und was dann am Ende auch noch hart ins Politische abrutscht, aber auf jeden Fall total spannend ist. Ich will jetzt am Ende das alles noch mal umkippen und fragen, wie man darüber spricht. Wir haben jetzt 1, 5 Stunden grob darüber geredet und haben ein, also nicht ein ganz grobes Konzept, aber sozusagen ein erstes Bild für die Themenlage vielleicht bei den geneigten ZuhörerInnen malen können. Das Spannende finde ich jetzt sozusagen, das ist ja eben sehr komplex, wie redet man denn darüber als jemand, der vom Fach ist? Ich würde die Runde nochmal zuteilen wollen. Und erstmal Vollkorn und Wolpertwo fragen wollen, wenn ihr sowas macht, dann macht ihr das ja wahrscheinlich auch für Firmen. Und Firmen haben ja die Eigenschaft, dass da Leute Entscheidungen treffen, die nicht immer Fachkompetenz innehaben. Und dann kann ich mir vorstellen, dass die, also Vollkorn hat es vorhin erzählt, ihr schreibt so eine Summary, steht dann drin, naja, es ist wahrscheinlich, aber es könnte auch, ha ha ha. Und jetzt könnte ich mir vorstellen, ich muss jetzt das plattklickieren, der Manager sagt so, ich will jetzt wissen wer das war, sag Bescheid hier. Wie kommuniziert man diese Themen so, dass sie verständlich sind, aber trotzdem nicht eben so vereinfacht werden können, dass halt der Manager dann sagen kann, ja der Vollkorn hat gesagt, die Russen waren's.
Oh ja, das ist tatsächlich eine Sache, die man echt üben muss. Also das ist mir als auch, also grundsätzlich in der IT-Security hat man häufig die Situation, dass man als Analyst die Tatsachen beschreibt und sagt, ich habe eine IP-Adresse entdeckt, von der ist der Angriff ausgegangen zum Beispiel. Und häufig gibt es dann aber auch die nächsten Instanzen, die dann erst tatsächlich diese Bewertung vornehmen. Also so ein bisschen auch wie zum Beispiel bei einem forensischen Labor von der Polizei. Der Forensiker, der sagt, ah guck mal, ich habe hier Blut gefunden und das Blut gehört nach DNA nur zu dieser Person. Aber der Forensiker wird jetzt nicht sagen, das ist der Mörder. Und ganz häufig ist es bei mir, in meinem Job habe ich auch dann so, dass ich sage, okay, das sind die Fakten, die ich gefunden habe. Und sie sind auf jeden Fall irgendwie mit diesem Angriff verknüpft auf diese Art und Weise. Und jetzt ist es aber dann vielleicht Aufgabe der Polizei zu bewerten, ob sie jetzt sich einen Durchsuchungsbefehl für diesen Server besorgen sollen. Das ist dann zum Glück meistens nicht mehr meine Sache, wo ich gefragt werde. Eine Entscheidung von zum Beispiel Sicherheitsbehörden oder auch von Unternehmen, die dann eine Risikobewertung machen und sagen, okay, wir haben hier jetzt von unseren Analysten die ganzen Faktenlage aufgetürmt bekommen. Und jetzt müssen wir uns entscheiden, der sagt, oh, es könnte gut sein, aber es geht die Situation, wie du gerade beschrieben hast. Und dann werden wir auch sagen, also das mache ich tatsächlich recht häufig, dass ich sage, pass mal auf, ich kann das nicht hundertprozentig sagen. Das, was ich hier in den Report geschrieben habe, ist meine professionelle Meinung. Und die ist halt nicht absolut sicher. Und ihr müsst jetzt für euch eine Risikobewertung machen, was ihr da für eine Aktion oder nicht machen wollt. Und da ziehe ich mich tatsächlich an der Stelle wirklich auch raus, weil ich kann eben genauso wenig wie jemand anderes die hundertprozentige Entscheidung geben.
Also ein Punkt ist auch, dass man da meistens relativ viel kommuniziert, optimalerweise auch eben bevor ein Bericht geschrieben wird, weil gerade Führungskräfte, die sind ja im Zweifelsfall da, auch in Krisen eben Entscheidungen zu treffen. Und die benötigen den Bericht nicht unbedingt, sondern die benötigen eben einfach, also entweder bestimmte Informationen, die sie aus ihren ureigenen Gründen eben brauchen. Oder eben natürlich möchten sie im Zweifelsfall, also gerade wenn das große Unternehmen sind, einfach eine Entscheidung treffen, die für sie das wenigste Risiko bedeutet, was natürlich dann auch nicht immer einfach ist, weil jetzt ist ja die Krise schon eingetreten und das Risiko kann eben niemand mehr wegzaubern. Das ist dann eben tatsächlich so, es ist auch, wenn jemand Schaden nimmt, es ist, wenn jemand ein sogenannter Erstbetroffener ist, dann ist es teilweise wirklich für die Leute extrem gespenstisch, mit welcher Leichtigkeit sich jemand durch das eigene Netz bewegt und vor allem auch, wenn sie sich dann Investitionen angucken. Also man hat ja dann meistens eben dann doch Geld für den Viren-Scanner oder so ausgegeben, für Antiswerm-Lösungen und das stellt sich dann natürlich alles als Fehlinvestition heraus, weil es hat ja nicht funktioniert. Dann muss man eben einfach mit dem Interesse entsprechend umgehen können und entweder sagen, wenn halt natürlich der Angriff sehr lange her ist, dann sind meistens die Spuren, die das Interesse wiedergeben, verfallen. Dann ist es natürlich schwierig zu sagen, dass das eben wahrscheinlich nicht festgestellt werden kann. Oder aber, das ist eben ein guter Punkt, dass man bei seiner Aufklärung ein, auch immer versucht herauszufinden, was wollte denn letztlich der Angreifer stehlen. Weil diese inhaltliche Information, die kann beispielsweise dafür sorgen, dass man sagt eben, guck mal, das hier wurde geklaut. Und auf einmal, wenn man das mit Leuten bespricht, stellt man raus, dass eben 60% der Leute in der Firma wissen, wer in Frage kommt, weil es einfach niemand anderen interessiert. Und das müssen sie einem natürlich nicht sagen. Manchmal haben ja Führungskräfte, die wissen auch, dass es bei manchen Produkten, da treten auch schon ohne Spionage, treten Klonprodukte auf. Wenn man in bestimmte Länder exportieren will, gibt es Schwierigkeiten. Man bekommt gewisse Genehmigungen nicht. Die Konkurrenz macht auf Messen, macht irgendwie komische Sprüche. Mitarbeiter werden abgeworben. Dann ist es dann manchmal so, dass es dann eben sozusagen auf einem großen Tisch von Problemen dann nur noch ein weiteres ist. Und dann wissen die schon Bescheid und können sich dann eben auch auf die Situation einstellen, dass es halt also wirklich dann eben Länder gibt, wo dann halt der Unternehmen irgendwas nicht zusammenschauen kann. Dann rennen sie eben weinend zum nächsten Sicherheitsdienst und der muss dann eben ihnen die Daten hacken. Also das ist eben wirklich, also wer einem sozusagen Schaden zufügt, das ist wirklich ein ureigenes Interesse herauszufinden, wer das ist. Und das gehört dann eben natürlich dazu, da diese Interessen in irgendeiner Form so gut geht zu bedienen. Oder im Zweifelsfall auch wirklich zu sagen, Leute, es ist zu lange her, diese Spuren sind weg. Und dann kommen dann eher Spezialisten dazu, die einfach sagen können, okay, was hat die Firma in der Zeit Interessantes gemacht? Aber das ist dann eben in dem Sinne kein Techniker mehr, sondern das ist eben jemand, der sich mit der Firma sehr gut auskennt und zweifelsfall mit dem Verhalten der Konkurrenz.
Ein sehr guter Punkt, den du angesprochen hast, weil in so einem Bericht gibt man üblicherweise Empfehlungen auch, wie man damit umgeht, wie man reagiert, was man für die Zukunft machen kann. Das sind in meinem Arbeitsbereich üblicherweise die spannenden Dinge, dass wir dann sagen, wir haben das und das entdeckt, wir empfehlen damit folgendermaßen umzugehen, z.B. schalte alle Rechner ab und mache eine genauere Analyse. Dann haben die Führungskräfte in der Situation immer die Möglichkeit zu sagen, wir wollen von diesen drei Vorschlägen, die ihr jetzt gemacht habt, das auswählen und dann ist der eine vielleicht der radikale, wo man alle Rechner runterfährt und der andere ist, wie wir schon vorhin besprochen haben, der Vorschlag, wir lassen das jetzt noch weiter laufen und gucken uns an. Wir versuchen da halt auch üblicherweise, bei mir sind es meistens Firmen, die zum Angriff betroffen sind und die brauchen natürlich Hilfe. Wir verstehen deren Geschäft nur in groben Zügen, weil wir das ja gerade erst kennengelernt haben. Und da ist dann halt immer dieses Entscheiden, was denn jetzt das Richtige ist. Ein Prozess, der zwischen beiden passiert.
Aber es ist sozusagen standardmäßig schon so, dass genug Verständnis dafür da ist, dass genau das passieren kann.
Also wir sagen es mal so, wenn das eine Organisation ist, die eigentlich auch historisch schon, also noch vielleicht bevor überhaupt Computer eine Rolle gespielt haben, wusste, dass es so etwas wie Industrie-Spionage, Konkurrenzspionage gibt, dann ist es natürlich für die nicht überraschend. Aber heutzutage, wir haben ja ein bisschen so dieses, überall zieht so dieses amerikanische Management-System ein, das ein Manager erst mal primär sich selbst schützt. Das heißt, der mag dann schon, der mag vielleicht dieses Verständnis haben, aber es kann sein, dass er dieses Verständnis nicht anwendet, weil einfach sein Ziel nur ist, möglichst gut aus der Situation rauszukommen. Und wenn das natürlich die Unternehmenskultur ist, dann ist das für alle Beteiligten, also wirklich vom sozusagen, vom ganz normalen Administrator bis sozusagen zu den Sicherheitsleuten, dann ist das für alle Beteiligten natürlich enorm anstrengend, weil so eine Organisation, die will das Verständnis gar nicht haben.
Na gut, das bleibt spannend. Ich würde es noch mal andersherum fragen, Hakan, ihr habt jetzt einen Podcast über das Thema gemacht. Und da muss es ja dann nicht nur verständlich für die EntscheiderInnen sein, sondern da gibt es ja auch noch zu sagen eine mutmaßliche Zielgruppe, die man bedienen muss, will, soll. Wie viel Arbeit, Nacharbeit, Mehrfachüberarbeitung des Kriptes hat das denn gebraucht, um dieses ganze komplexe System so aufzuarbeiten, dass es dann zufriedenstellend für alle war?
Also ich glaube dadurch, dass weder Florian noch ich einen Background in Informatik haben. Also ich kann ein bisschen programmieren und so weiter, aber das Einmaleins check ich vielleicht, aber die Sachen, über die wir dann berichten, sind ja dann schon sehr hardcore spezifisch gewesen. Das ist dann meistens so, dass ich Gespräche einfach dreimal für viermal für und die Geduld und Nettigkeit der Leute, die mit uns reden, krass strapaziere, um es dann auf eine Art und Weise zu erzählen, dass es technisch akkurat ist und passt und irgendwie spannend ist hoffentlich. Und dann haben wir in dem konkreten Fall tatsächlich das anderen Leuten vorgelesen und haben geguckt, an welchen Stellen stolpern die, an welchen Stellen kommen die nicht mit und dann noch einmal noch mehr Leuten vorgelesen, nachdem wir es überarbeitet haben und nach zweimal Vorlesen war klar, okay, so müsste das jetzt ungefähr passen und trotzdem irgendwie spannend genug sein, dass es auch die Leute hören wollen, die die technischen Details interessieren. Also beide Leute, beide Gruppierungen zu erreichen, meines Ziels. Ich hoffe, dass es geklappt hat.
Na gut, davon müsst ihr euch selber ein Bild machen. Genau, ich würde an dieser Stelle zum Ende kommen wollen, fand es sehr spannend. Oder vielleicht letzte Frage noch an alle und wir machen nochmal eine Runde. Weil wir jetzt die ganze Zeit darüber geredet haben, wie Leute in Systeme einbrechen und was alles für fütterliche Dinge passieren können. Und wie schwierig das alles ist, dagegen vorzugehen. Wird es schlimmer? Also müssen wir uns darauf einstellen, alle Systeme werden für immer gehackt, es sei denn gezielt, weil wir Spionagedings sind oder als Beifang, weil irgendwas unsicher war. Oder ist das sozusagen eine Entwicklung? Also ja, es wird immer Probleme geben, aber es wird jetzt nicht maßgeblich schlimmer oder nicht. Was ist da euer Eindruck? Vollkorn und Wolpertwo aus der Arbeit, Hakan, vielleicht sozusagen nach dem Podcast.
Ich fange mal kurz an, weil IT-Security so allgemein, ich habe das Gefühl, vor irgendwie 20 Jahren, als das Feld groß wurde, da haben ganz viele Leute die Einstellung gehabt, wir machen jetzt IT-Security, aber das wird nicht lang gehen, weil wir werden bald alles abgesichert haben und dann haben wir uns selber in unserem Job obsolet gemacht. Und das stellt sich jetzt als leichter Tugschluss raus. Und immer mehr habe ich den Eindruck, man kann so viele Leute auf dieses Problem werfen, wie man möchte, es gibt einfach genug zu tun, es ist ein absolutes Mangelfeld, also man findet nicht genügend Leute für die IT-Security, Forensik und all solche Sachen. Und es wird einfach immer mehr, es wird nicht weniger, so sage ich das mal lieber, was es zu tun gibt. Es verändert sich zwar, die Sicherheitsmaßnahmen werden besser, die Betriebssysteme, die Cold-Qualität von Microsoft zum Beispiel hat sich seit den letzten 20 Jahren deutlich verbessert und solche Dinge. Aber es kommt auch immer mehr neue Komplexität, neue Angriffsflächen hinzu, neue Angriffstechniken. Man spürt halt auch, dass durch die besseren Sicherungsmaßnahmen die Angreiferinnen einen höheren Druck haben und kreativer werden. Und neue Konzepte sich überlegen. Also ich glaube, da wird sich viel verändern und es wird die ganze Zeit was passieren, aber es wird immer weitergehen.
Okay, wir werden nicht alle sterben. Nicht auf einmal zumindest, hoffentlich. Hakan, hat sich für dich nach dem Podcast das Verständnis von der IT-Sicherheit verändert?
Also ich finde dieses Thema Attribution wahnsinnig spannend. Und ich habe durch den Podcast, auch wenn ich mich in den Jahren zuvor immer damit beschäftigt habe, dadurch, dass ich den Luxus hatte, dass mein Arbeitgeber gesagt hat, schaust du dir einfach fünf Monate an, kann ich jetzt über dieses Thema Attribution auf eine Art und Weise reden, wo ich sage, okay, das finde ich in sich schlüssig, um deine eigentliche Frage zu beantworten. Ich habe schon den Eindruck, also es ist ein bisschen Zwiegespalten. Auf der einen Seite, Vollkorn hat es ja angedeutet, wenn man so Google-Produkte verwendet, kann man zu Google stehen, wie man will, aber Gmail ist einfach erstmal sicher. Oder Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung. Oder wenn man seine Systeme back-up-t und die aktuellsten Betriebssysteme verwendet, dann läuft man erstmal nicht Gefahr, direkt zwangsläufig gehackt zu werden. Auf der anderen Seite, dadurch, dass es diese krasse Monopolisierung gibt, lohnt es sich für die Hacker halt auch einfach, nach diesen Sicherheitsnücken zu gucken, weil wenn ich was bei Exchange gefunden habe, dann sind halt all diese Landschaften, in denen Microsoft eingesetzt wird, mit einem Schlag offen. Deswegen geht es so in beide Richtungen. Ich glaube aber, für Privatpersonen ist es viel, viel, viel einfacher geworden, die eigenen Systeme zu sichern. Einfach durch Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung alleine schon.
Wolpertwo, du zum Schluss auch noch?
Ja, also ich glaube, Zwei-Faktoren spielen da eine Rolle, die das teilweise eher schlechter machen. Das eine ist, dass die Renzenwehrgruppen beziehungsweise Leute mit Adressungsprojekten, die verdienen gerade Geld und ziehen damit natürlich auch andere Leute in den Bereich rein, weil die eben einfach damit sehen, dass man je nachdem, in welchem Land man arbeitet, mit einer erfolgreichen Operation halt mehr verdienen kann, wie wenn man dort das ganze Jahr arbeitet. Und wenn natürlich kriminelle Geld haben, dann machen sie natürlich, kaufen sich damit nicht nur Luxus, sondern sie investieren auch wieder. Also sie können mehr Exportautoren bezahlen. Sie können noch bequemere Arbeitsabläufe sich ausdenken. Und das spielt sicher gerade eine größere Rolle. Also das sorgt sicher für eine Verschlechterung der Situation. Und das andere ist auch, was Cloud-Technologien angeht, das ist auch ein bisschen deprimierend, weil das sind immer mehr so Sachen, in denen Sicherheit intransparent ist, weil die Hersteller überall alle normalen Fachbegriffe, die man aus der IT kennt, umbenennen, damit das eben so Alleinstellungsmerkmale sind. Also wer zum Beispiel weiß, was ein Microsoft-Blob ist. Und da ist es dann eben so, dass das eben oft sehr intransparent ist. Und gerade so bei den Angriffen rund um Solarwines, Hersteller von Netzwerkechnologie, da hat es eben auch viele Opfer gegeben, unter anderem Sicherheitsunternehmen, die sind alleine deswegen gehackt worden, weil sie sich eigentlich mit normaler Sicherheit gut auskennen, aber tatsächlich eben offensichtlich ihre Cloud-Technologien einfach nicht genug verstanden haben. Und das sind natürlich auch Sachen, die sind auf Verkauf getrimmt. Und auch Microsoft bemüht sich da natürlich, dass man das eben sicher machen kann. Aber kaufen tut man es erstmal in einem unsicheren Zustand. Und das ist halt das Problem für jedes Unternehmen, was keine eigene Sicherheitsabteilung ist. Das ist eben davon abhängig, dass Software und Systeme im Auslieferungszustand eben sicher sind. Und da haben wir meiner Meinung nach in dem Bereich, da sehe ich ehrlich gesagt nur Rückschritte. Wenn jetzt jemand kommt und sagt Wahlcomputer in die Cloud, dann würde ich mir wirklich so schnell wie möglich die nächste Alkoholquelle suchen.
Ja, also ich sage mal so, ich glaube für den optimistischen Ausblick hat man das Chaosradio noch nie gehört. Also Hakan, Vollkorn, Wolpertwo, vielen Dank, dass ihr heute da wart und so ausführlich Rede und Antwort gestalten habt zu diesem doch überraschenden, nicht so ganz einfachen Thema. Aber wir konnten vielleicht eine kleine Einführung geben. Vielen Dank euch nochmal. Und das war Folge 268 des Chaosradios. Nächsten Monat geht es wahrscheinlich um eine sehr wichtige Technologie, die man sogar fünffach übereinander stapeln kann. Mehr möchte ich an dieser Stelle noch nicht sagen. Nur noch eins, lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschüsselt immer schön eure Backups.